Die Ligatour Europa ist wieder zurück. Wir wollen sprechen über die Liga, mit David Frogier de Pont-Lévin. Ja, ihr habt richtig gehört. Über La Liga mit Alex Troika, über die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, über die Serie A mit Christian Bernhardt und über die Eredivise mit Daniel Zander. Es wird höchste Zeit, dass wir loslegen.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Rest in Peace erstmal an alle, die das auf doppelter Geschwindigkeit gehört haben. Sorry, dass ich so schnell geworden bin am Anfang, aber ey, bei so vielen Gästen und wie schön ist es euch alle mal wieder hier zu haben. Wie immer mache ich das kollektive Hallo, hallo in die Runde.
Hallo, Halli hallo.
Reaktionszeit diesmal besser als beim letzten Mal. Das ist immer eigentlich ein ganz guter Lackmustest. Und nachdem er so lange nicht mehr hier war, fangen wir natürlich mit David an. David, wie schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist, uns über die Liga hellen willst. Was hast du uns denn mitgebracht an Themen?
Guten Morgen. An Themen soll ich beide gleich…
Nein, mach erst mal eins.
Ich fange mal mit dem Spiel an, das es hier am Freitag gab, also nicht hier, sondern in Frankreich in der Liga. Da war ein Spielstart, das es zuletzt eher selten gab, letztmals 1980 in der Gruppe B der 2. Liga. Damals sprichten da auch Vereine wie die AA. Géblos noch in der Gruppe B der 2. Liga. Das war Rennes gegen Paris FC. Das hat im Grunde zwei Geschichten, eine auf dem Platz, eine neben dem Platz. Wir lieben ja im Rasenfunk die Geschichten neben dem Platz, mit Investoren usw. Neben dem Platz war es die Story der zwei der reichsten Männer Frankreichs, insbesondere zwei der größten Luxus-Konglomerate Frankreichs. Auf der einen Seite Berner Arnaud, den kennt man ja vielleicht als zwischenzeitlich mal reichster Mann der Welt. Dem gehören u.a. Louis Vuitton, Dior, diverse Alkohol- und Champagnermarken, Ua, Schmuck usw. und Medienhäuser. Privatvermögen 160 Milliarden und eben auch 52 Prozent von Paris FC. Und auf der anderen Seite François Pinot. Der war eigentlich in den 60er Jahren erst im Holzhandel tätig. Dann hat er in Einzelhandelketten gemacht. Und schließlich ist er in den 90ern ebenfalls in Luxusmarken eingestiegen. Dem gehören heute sowas wie Yves Saint Laurent, Puma, Spirituosen, Schmuckhersteller, blablabla. Legendärerweise wollte er 1999 Gucci übernehmen. Das hat er auch gemacht. Und das wollte Kollege Berner und Ouno eigentlich auch. Seitdem gibt es Stress und Rivalität. Es scheint tatsächlich so, dass die beiden immer auch versuchen, ihre Duftmarken da zu setzen, wo der andere gerade ist. Wenn irgendjemand einen Laden macht, dann macht der andere da auch einen auf. Oder wenn der Geschäftssteller kommt, eine Regionale, dann kommt der andere auch. Und wenn Pinot für den Wiederaufbau von Notre Dame mal 100 Millionen spendet, dann spendet Arnaud am Tag darauf das Doppelte.
Oh, die könnten Rasenfunk-Supporter werden wegen mir.
So, und deswegen gab es natürlich auch prompt einen Namen für dieses Duell zwischen Paris und Rennes. Also der Milliardärico oder der Klassico, also Co mit C-A-U-L-T, weil ja Pinot gegen Arnaud. Oder eben der Lüxico, fand ich am schönsten. Der Lüxico. Und das wurde ja auch vor dem Match runtergespielt. Das großartigste Zitat dazu habe ich vom Präsidenten des Aufsichtsrats vom Startrennen gelesen. Also nein, nein, man sieht das gar nicht als wirtschaftliche Revalität. Das ist ja klar auf die Wirtschaftsinvestitionen bezogen. Bei Fußball und moderner Kunst, da geht es um Passion. Ich lasse das mal hier so im Raum stehen, Fußball und moderne Kunst. Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber wir wissen jetzt also Fußball und moderne Kunst, da geht es um Passion. Man muss auch tatsächlich sagen, Pinot ist jetzt im Gegensatz zu Arnaud, der erst vor kurzem eingestiegen ist. Pinot ist schon seit den Neunzigern aktiv bei Rennen. Da wurde insbesondere Anfang sehr massiv investiert. Und ja, es wurde zwischendrin immer wieder auch mal die Schatulle aufgemacht. Aber das waren häufiger, das kennen wir auch von anderen Investoren, ja, das waren häufiger dann ausgerechnet die Jahre, wo es dann gar nicht so lief, weil dann irgendwie viele Neue reinkamen. Und zuletzt hat sich ja Rennes eigentlich eher in Namen gemacht, wieder aus der eigenen Jugend hochzuziehen, teuer zu verkaufen. Da haben sie ja sehr, sehr große Trans-Test-Fluss gehabt. Da kommen ja große Namen her, Kamaringer, Martis Tell und so weiter. Und ich wollte eigentlich über Rennes sprechen, aber zumindest mal so zwei, drei Sätze zu Paris FC. Ich glaube, dann müssen wir sowieso mal irgendwie ein Rasenfunk Ligatour-Segment dazu machen. Das ist ja sowieso eine ganz spannende Sache. Die sind jetzt eben da mit dem Androhgeld ausgestattet. Und noch dieser 10%-Beteiligung von Red Bull und diversalen Sponsoren, die gibt es seit 1969. Die sind ja zusammen entstanden, oder mehr oder weniger zusammen entstanden mit PSG. Das ist diese verrückte Story, wo es hieß, wir brauchen unbedingt einen Fußballklub in Paris, einen großen. Und die spielen eine ganz ordentliche Saison. Und vor allem haben sie bis zu diesem Spieltag in jedem Spiel mindestens ein Tor erzielt. Und ich habe eine wunderschöne Statistik gefunden vor dem Spiel. Da hatten sie vor dem Spiel den zweitbesten Schnitt unter allen Aufsteigern der fünf großen Ligen. Also bei erzählten Toren pro Spiel. Vor dem Spieltag waren es 1,6. Ich habe das extra nochmal für euch, für den Rasenfunk nachgerechnet. Sie haben nämlich kein Tor erzielt. Also sind wir bei 1,5. 18 Tore in 12 Spielen. Und jetzt die Preisfrage. Wer ist erster?
In dieser Kategorie. Immer ein Tor als Aufsteiger der 1. FC Köln.
Der 1. FC Köln, richtig. Mit 17 Toren in 10 Spielen.
Die anderen einfach überhaupt nicht beeindruckt sind. Ich hasse euch alle, aber egal. Mach weiter, David.
Danach Levante mit 1,3 und Sassuolo, Burnley und Sunderland mit 1,27. Die haben alle drei 14 Tore in 11 Spielen. Und extra für Ligatour habe ich auch noch mal in die Eredivise reingeschaut und der FC Wohldamm hat 16 Tore in 12 Spielen. Also 1,33333. Ich wusste ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass der FC Wohldamm existiert. Ich habe es jetzt hier mit gelernt.
Schatzfeier.
Pardon.
Herzlich willkommen zurück.
Ja.
So wie lief denn jetzt das Spiel zwischen Paris und Rennes?
Genau. Wie lief das Spiel und was ist eigentlich mit Rennes? Ich habe auch dafür nochmal reingehört in den Rasenfunk. Das letzte Mal, als Rennes erwähnt worden ist, ist November 2024. Da war Alexi da und hat ein Segment gemacht über Chaos bei Rennes. Und schon orakelt, dass er... Gut.
Also es war wieder Donnerstag.
Und er hatte orakelt, dass Sampaoli bald wieder entlassen wird. Und da hatte er recht. Im Januar war es so weit. Sampaoli war schon wieder Geschichte. Er hatte damals geglaubt, dass Frank Ayes kommen wird. Zu dem kommen wir später noch. Aber nein, der kam nicht nach Rennes. Es kam Abib Bey. Und Abib Bey ist eine ziemlich spannende Figur. Ich weiß nicht, ob da spontan was ringelt. Verteidiger, 150 für Marseille und dann nochmal 50 für Newcastle. Und war dann auch ganz kurz bei Essenbiller. Und war dann aber in Frankreich bekannt, weil er Moderator war einige Jahre. Und zwar ein ziemlich beliebter Moderator, der ziemlich gut einordnen konnte. Bei allem, was Mikrofon hat in Frankreich, also Kanal Plus und der Radio und Fernseher Jean Afterfood und Radio France International, die kann man heute immer noch als Podcast hören. Das ist eine ganz coole Sendung. Die haben auch immer einen schönen Blick auf Afrika. Und dann schließt sich jetzt hier ein erster Kreis, weil seine erste Trainerstation war Red Star Paris. Und Red Star Paris ist ja jetzt im Gegensatz zu diesen Emporkömmlingen da, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, der eigentlich wahre, historische, mythische Club, 1897 von Jury mehr gegründet. Genau, wurden leider mittlerweile von 777 gekauft und dann wieder weiterverkauft, als 777 Probleme hat. Egal, jedenfalls mit Red Star ist Beye in die 2. Liga aufgestiegen und sein Co-Trainer war ein gewisser PSH, der ist auch vor kurzem im Rasenfunk aufgetaucht hier. Der ist nämlich derjenige, der gerade bei Lance für Wirbel sorgt und mit denen ganz viel macht. Und Beye sagt auch immer wieder, Sage habe eben da unglaublich viel geholfen und eben das Positionsspiel nochmal näher gebracht und so. Das sei ihm da sehr dankbar. So, und dann ging er jedenfalls nach Rennes im Januar 25, als dritter Trainer des Klubs, weil, wie gesagt, war ja Chaos in der Saison. Stapel diese in den Klub, bringt da seine Spielphilosophie rein und hatte jetzt einen recht merkwürdigen Saisonstart. Der fing nämlich erstmal an mit einem schönen Sieg über Marseille, das war jenes Spiel, wo danach Roux und Rabiot entlassen wurden, weil Marseille ja gegen Rennes verloren hat. Also Rennes mit Auftaktsieg und dann ist aber erstmal irgendwie Sand im Getriebe drin und alles klemmt irgendwie. 14-0 klatschen gegen Lorient, unentschieden, blablabla. Und Beye stand tatsächlich kurz vorm Rauswurf. Also die letzten Wochen waren immer wieder so, ah ja, okay, wird er jetzt entlassen, so Schicksalsspiel, blablabla. Und Beye hat was ziemlich bemerkenswertes gemacht. Er hat einige große Namen auf die Bank besetzt dann. Fofana, Bril Embolo, Merlin und stellt dafür junge Spieler auf. Kada Mete, 18, Jaussi C, 21. Und feiert dann vor einer Woche einen absolut großartigen, großartigen Sieg gegen Straßburg, 4-0-1. Über die hattet ihr auch schon gesprochen. Die waren ja gerade so high flyer. Damals hat er erstmal deren Serie gestoppt. Und jetzt hat er gegen Paris FC wieder dasselbe gemacht. Fofana kam erst zur 83-Minute. Mbolo kam erst zur 66-Minute. Und Mbolo war es dann aber auch, der den Siegstreffer gemacht hat. Und der wird aber jetzt im Interview zitiert. Ja, ne, ne, er sehe das auch ein, dass er da großer Bruder und Mentor für die jüngeren Stürmer sei. Das sei ja absolut fantastisch, was man da im Kader habe. So eben nur so Leute wie Kader, Maite.
Ja, ist denn Mbolo jetzt 28? Ja, okay, gut, da kann man sich schon als Mentor bezeichnen. In meinem Kopf ist der immer 22.
Ja, ja, er hat ja auch schon eine Phase hinter sich. Naja, und der Rest war Arbeitssieg, ehrlich gesagt. Also Paris hatte sehr viele Chancen, teilweise Pech. Rennes hatte einen großartigen Brice Samba im Tor. Und es plätscherte ansonsten so ein bisschen dahin, muss ich sagen. Ich habe es mir dann auch voll angeschaut. Ja, also es war ein dreckiger Arbeitssieg nach dem Glanzsieg sozusagen. Aber es meint man ja genau das, was man so braucht, um die Saison kick zu starten nach dem Oh Gott, oh Gott, ich werde entlassen.
Okay, das heißt, wir wissen jetzt Bescheid, was bei Rennes passiert ist in den letzten anderthalb Jahren. Wenn Beye, also als er so zornig war über seine etablierten Spiele, die er aussortiert hat, also er war salty, hat man ihn dann Salt-Bey genannt? Das waren die 30 Sekunden wert, oder, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Schreibt mir.
Ich glaube, es gab einige Kommentare, die schon Bei-bei geschrieben haben, Social Media.
Ja, sehr schön.
Ist noch nicht so weit.
Da freut sich der alte Topmüller, wenn man sagt Bei-bei rennen. Also Rennes steht ja damit jetzt dann auch ganz in Ordnung da, Rang 8. Und für Paris ist ja auch nicht viel passiert, was ist ja schon eingeordnet, sind sind gut mit dabei, hatten diesen tollen Toreschnitt und jetzt so arg wie schlimmer ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Genau und haben nach wie vor das viele Geld. Also ich glaube, da von denen hören wir noch in den nächsten Jahren zumindest. Das wird noch spannend oder?
Gott sei Dank haben sie Geld. Das ist meine größte Sorge. Im Fußball gibt es so wenig Geld. Gut, dann wissen wir jetzt, wie der Lyxico ausgegangen ist. Und schauen vielleicht mal.
Parfum schießt keine Tore.
Wie bitte? Wer schießt keine Tore?
Aber in dem Fall.
Parfum schon. Wenn er nicht gerade verletzt war.
Dieser Seidfalz hier zum Tor des Monats damals. Ach, das war ein Ding. Okay, komm Uli, dann bist du jetzt dran. Hast dich reingesnickt. Schauen wir in die Premier League. Wird glaube ich mal Zeit, dass wir über Manchester City sprechen. Alle anderen haben wir schon mal so angesprochen. Liverpool ganz am Anfang der Saison. Jetzt dann Arsenal in der letzten Sendung. Aber ist City vielleicht das eigentliche Thema gerade?
Ja, zumindest spannend, weil ich bin doch nicht 100% klug, wer sie sind, wie gut sie sind und so. Und deswegen finde ich es sehr, sehr interessant, nachdem sie jetzt 3-0 gegen Liverpool dahin zaubern. Man könnte jetzt über Liverpool grundsätzlich das Gleiche sagen, aber ja, finde ich ein sehr spannendes Team im Moment. Und ich habe noch kein finales Urteil mir bilden können, weil es auch innerhalb eines Spiels teilweise mal so, mal so aussieht, sodass wir das tun können, über Manchester City sprechen.
Aber jetzt war es ja in der Vergangenheit eigentlich immer so, dass wenn City am Beginn der Saison im Herbst ein paar Punkte hat liegen lassen, dann wurde mir ja von beiden Hebels immer erzählt, ja völlig egal. Die gewinnen ja sowieso ab Januar dann wieder alles und werden dann Meister. Im Grunde ist ja eigentlich in dieser Saison noch nichts anderes passiert. Es gab eine Niederlage gegen Ersten Villa und halt zwei an Spieltagen 2 und 3. Ist das quasi noch so die Skepsis aus der Vorsaison, die da bei dir vorheft? Ja.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich glaube aber auch übrigens bei den Spielern. Man hat manchmal innerhalb eines Spiels so ein Gefühl, dass die auch denken, oh, vielleicht ist dem Frieden noch nicht so zu trauen, wie man es nimmt. Aber ja, das kommt daher, weil logischerweise jetzt im Sommer schon einiges umgebaut worden ist. Das ist schon eine andere Truppe. Die spielen auch in Teilen anders. Also zunächst, die haben ja per Blindest verpflichtet. Und das ist genau das, was ich meine. Also vor dem Champions-League-Spiel gegen Borussia Dortmund zum Beispiel war mein Urteil und das, was ich mir so aufgeschrieben habe. Die versuchen, quasi Liverpool-Pressing-Fußball zu spielen. Und jetzt, wenn man mal auf das Personal schaut, die da vorne drauf pressen sollen, dann sieht man, dass das halt im Vergleich totale Leichtgewichte sind. Also die können das einfach nicht so, wie die Intensität, die Liverpool da vorne drin hat in der Offensive. Und dann kommt aber witzigerweise so eine Woche jetzt dabei rum. Dortmund, das klammere ich jetzt nochmal aus, aber dann vor allen Dingen in Liverpool, wo dann zwei verschiedene Cities innerhalb eines Spiels zu sehen sind. Nämlich zum einen ein Manchester City, das auch mal in den Block fällt, was total erstaunlich ist. Das tut ihnen super, super, super gut. Und dann gibt es aber auch wieder eins, das total, wie soll man sagen, uneitel fast Konterfußball spielt über Doku, der in der Disziplin einfach ein Monster ist. Mit dem habe ich ansonsten so meine Schwierigkeiten, weil wenn City wirklich um den 16er rumspielt und er den Ball hat, dann stoppt er ganz viel und dann zieht er zwei auf sich und dann ist er eigentlich leicht zu verteidigen. Sobald aber ein Diagonalball auf ihn zum Beispiel gelöst wird, was willst du dann machen gegen den? Und da gibt es noch diverse mehr, die sie haben. Harlan ist eh in einer Form, die ist unglaublich, selbst für seine Verhältnisse, auch wenn er spielerisch noch weniger eingebunden ist als in den Jahren zuvor. Aber die Zahlen sind natürlich frappierend.
Also 14 Tore in elf Spielen für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben und er hat nur in zwei Premier League Spielen überhaupt nicht getroffen. Insgesamt steht er bei 165 Torbeteiligungen in 161 Spielen für City.
Das ist schon Wahnsinn. Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, dass die letzte Saison– selbst die letzte Saison– wäre für jeden normalen Stürmer eine richtig gute gewesen. Für seine Verhältnisse war es halt, naja, aber immer noch richtig gut.
Also nur 22 Tore, da hat er ganz schön geschwächelt.
Genau, das war nix. Ja, nee, und das ist der Grund bei City, warum ich noch nicht 100% weiß, wer sie sind. Weil eigentlich, also zum Beispiel so ein Reindas, von dem ich dachte, dass der jemand sein müsste, der total diktiert, also so was wie ein De Bruyne ersetzt, der eigentlich nicht ersetzt ist. Das muss man so klar sagen. Also mir fehlt schon dieser Spieler, der dir quasi einfach mal ein Spiel packen kann und es entscheiden könnte. Ich hatte und habe auch weiterhin so ein bisschen meinen Stress mit den Savinios, Phil Fohns, Docuus. Das sind alles so Zocker, die gerne im Halbraum mal aufdrehen, aber die halt selten mal ein Spiel wirklich am Laufen halt mit der richtigen Entscheidung sind. Sie sind eigentlich relativ leicht ausrechenbar. Plus eben, dass sie sind gewogen und für mich als zu soft teilweise, ja einfach dann befunden. Da hatte ich so meine Schwierigkeiten, habe ich auch weiterhin. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich ihnen noch nicht 100% nicht Richtung Contendership vertraue, sondern warum ich immer noch denke, dass es eventuell so sein könnte, dass die da ihre Schwierigkeiten haben würden. Jeder von den Innenverteidigern hat so seine Schwächen gehabt. In Stones Fall zum Beispiel Verletzungsbedingungen, aber eigentlich wie immer. Und Ruben Diasch hat eine komische Saison letztes Jahr gespielt, der ist wieder einigermaßen stabilisiert. Sie hatten so ein ganz komisches Hin und Her auf der Linksverteidiger-Position. Eine Zeit lang dachte ich schon im September, das ist jetzt O'Reilly's Position, dann passt das auch einigermaßen, weil der zumindest die Größe mitbringt. Dann hat er wieder begonnen, plötzlich Guardiola zweimal in Folge zu bringen, der mir auf Linksverteidiger einfach nicht so gut gefällt wie Innenverteidiger. Dann hat er sogar noch mal versucht, noch mal was zu wechseln, was dann wiederum auch Auswirkungen auf die Rechtsverteidigerposition hatte, von der ich einfach denke, dass Matthäus Nunes inzwischen von einem durchschnittlichen Mittelfeldspieler zu einem der besten Rechtsverteidiger der Welt geworden ist, an einem guten Tag. Der hat aber auch noch immer mal einen schlechten Tag drin. Und dieses Rodri-Thema ist halt einfach immer noch eins. Also wir hatten jetzt Ewigkeiten im Oktober wieder, die Situation ist er fit, ist er nicht fit. Alle zwei, drei Tage ist die Frage gestellt worden. Es sah bei Weitem nicht so aus, als könnte der zwei Mal in einer Woche spielen. Genau und daher ist es so ein bisschen, ich weiß es noch nicht. Ich weiß es noch nicht. Ich habe sie irgendwie so im Verfolgerfeld auf zwei und drei. Aber was sie letztlich sind, schwer zu sagen.
Immerhin sind sie auf jeden Fall auch schon mal defensiv stark. Also man spricht halt immer über die Offensive bei City, aber es ist halt nach Arsene nicht nur jetzt von den kassierten Toren, also von den Gegentoren, sondern auch statistisch gesehen einfach die zweisbeste Defensive. Und da muss sie jetzt ja nicht mal ins Phrasenschwein zahlen, damit allen klar ist, was das bedeutet.
Ja und es hängt im Übrigen auch an Donnarumma, weil die wenigen Situationen, die auf ihn kamen, also auch wenn man vor allen Dingen in Champions League mitnimmt, die hat er halt gut gemacht. Und ich finde auch, es ist sehr viel darüber diskutiert worden, ist Donnarumma ein Guardiola-Tor heute. Da ist er nicht natürlich mit Ball am Fuß, das ist uns ja eigentlich klar. Aber es gab ja auch ein Workaround bei Paris Saint-Germain, als der im Tor war. Du kannst halt nicht ganz so fluide spielen, sondern musst halt hier und da mal Positionen, sag ich mal, umbauen, damit er halt rausspielen kann. Der macht es aber viel besser, als sein Ruf ist. Also der ist mit Ball am Fuß viel– also der ist jetzt kein Virtuose, das ist kein Mittelfeldspieler wie ein Guardiola, der ja gerne hätte und, sind wir ehrlich, auch eine Zeit lang gehabt hat in Ederson, in der guten Version von Ederson. Er macht es okay, er macht es insgesamt gut. Er ist mit den Reflexen auch in den, das ist ja auch etwas, was man braucht als Torhüter. Wenn es dann mal so 10 Minuten off gibt bei City und die gibt es immer noch, wenn was schief läuft, dann ist er auch mal mit einer Parade da, wenn ein klarer Torschluss zustande kommt und hält sie drin im Spiel und gibt aus meiner Sicht einen deutlich präsenteren Rückhalt, als das Ederson jetzt all die Jahre gewesen ist. Zum Teil auch Ortega letzte Saison, wer er dann gespielt hat. Das heißt, auch da liegt es sicherlich auch ein bisschen an dem, dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Sehr gut, wir werden City im Blick behalten und über die Torhütersituation, na eigentlich über einige Themen, kann man an Barca anknüpfen, finde ich, Alex. Wenn wir als nächstes über die sprechen, es reichen aber vielleicht schon einfach zwei Zahlen, die ich nennen kann bei Barca. Das eine ist eine 3, das waren die Gegentore, die man gegen Brücke gefangen hat. Und jeder, der dieses Spiel irgendwie mitverfolgt hat, der weiß, da ist man mit einem Punkt vielleicht sogar noch ganz gut rausgekommen und gegen Celta Vigo auch schon wieder zwei Gegentore kassiert. Damals, als Hansi Flick übernommen hat bei Barca, da waren wir uns hier alle in der Runde einig. Also ich glaube, Daniel war nicht mit dabei, also der muss sich jetzt nicht mit gemeint fühlen. Das wird schwierig, weil wir ja gesehen haben, wie es im Nationalteam, im Deutschen dann auseinander ging und wie bei Bayern auch ein Problem war, dass die Restverteidigung nur ein Restchen oft war und man deswegen zu viele Tore kassiert hat. Hansi Flick hat uns eines Besseren belehrt, und zwar so dermaßen, war bestimmt einer der besten Trainer, erfolgreichsten Trainer der letzten Saison. Ist das jetzt der Redemption-Ark unsererseits? Also kommt jetzt das, was wir alle erwartet haben, oder woran liegt das, Alex, dass es gerade so defensiv ungeordnet ist bei Barca?
Ja, ein bisschen passt das ganz gut, wenn du das so vergleichst. Es sieht wieder so aus, wie es gar nicht aussehen darf, wie es im schlechtesten Fall aussah. Gerade bei der deutschen Nationalmannschaft, die Restverteidigung ist Vogelwild. Ich glaube, das kann man so wirklich...
Grau ganz wild.
Grau ganz wild. Oh, schön. Und ja, welche Gründe das hat? Ich glaube, das hat viele Gründe. Es hat auch Teilgründe. Einer ist sicherlich auch die Torwart-Geschichte und Position. Da wollte ich übrigens bei Uli anknüpfen. Es gibt einen guten spielenden Torwart, der im Winter verfügbar sein könnte, Uli. In Katalonien. Für Pep.
Das hätte auch überragend gepasst. Ich habe zwei verschiedene Torhüter-Trainer gefragt, die beide gesagt haben, oh ja, das wäre eigentlich der Oberfit.
Das wäre ein Fit, ja. Um da anzuknüpfen, um bei dem Thema zu bleiben, ja, Cezny spielt ja aktuell, weil Garcia, der Neuzugang, der wirklich grandios, eine grandiose Start bei Barca hingelegt hat, weil der sich ja verletzt hat. Ich glaube, Meniskus-OP, auch was schwerwiegendes. Ter Stegen, über den wir gesprochen haben, fällt mit Rücken aus, ist jetzt aber quasi, ich glaube, er steigt jetzt bald wieder ins Training ein oder ist wieder zurück. Aber ja, mit Cezny hast du eher so die Donnarummer-Geschichte in, viel älter und ein bisschen betagter. Und der passt natürlich bei dieser verrückten Defensivlinie nicht so gut rein, weil er eben kein mitspielender Torwart ist. Und auch das ist ein Teilgründchen, wenn sie da schon so hochschieben, dass du hinten raus keinen hast, der mal Manu der Libero-mäßig rauskommt aus dem Tor oder mitspielend ist. Oder wenn er rauskommt, ist er zögerlich. Und das ist ein Grund. Inigo Martinez ist ein Hauptgrund, den haben sie im Sommer ablösefrei in die Wüste ziehen lassen, wegen des Salary Caps, weil sie da irgendwie mal wieder Gehalt einsparen mussten. Und das war der Abwehrchef schlechthin, vor allem der Abseitsfallen-Chef bei Barca letztes Jahr, der das wirklich koordiniert hat. Der der Boss da hinten war, neben Cuba Sidi, dem 18-, 19-Jährigen, der das natürlich toll macht. Ich glaube, Uli und ich haben ihn auch hochgelobt, aber eben nur ein 18-, 19-Jähriger ist. Also der Abseitsfallen-Chef war Inigo Martinez. Der fehlt dir. Das ist ein Grund. Dann ist das Pressing nicht mehr so scharf, weil das ist ja die Grundvoraussetzung. Sie pressen ja so gut gegen den Ball, dass das die Voraussetzung ist, dass die Abseitsfalle überhaupt zu hoch schieben kann. Das ist nicht mehr so giftig. Das hat auch mit Verletzungen zu tun. Gavi beispielsweise fällt ja auch schwer verletzt aus. Ich glaube auch wieder Knie, Meniskus. Dann hatten sie kleinere Verletzungen. Jetzt ist wieder Pedri außen vor. Olmo fehlt ja immer wieder, sprich weniger Rotationen, weniger Ruhephasen für die Spieler. Ein Pedri musste durchspielen, ein Frenkie de Jong musste durchspielen. Also da gibt es ein paar Gründchen. Dann Kundés Form ist nicht die der letzten Saison, muss man auch ehrlich zugeben, der eigentlich auf der rechtsverteidigen Position eine Bank ist. Wirklich eine absolute Weltklasse-Bank. Der schwimmt so eher mit, ist einfach nicht so gut drauf. Und so hast du ein paar Gründchen, die zusammenkommen. Und natürlich ein weiterer Grund ist, irgendwann weiß jeder Verein, jeder Club, egal ob es Brügge ist, ob es Girona ist, ob es Helter ist, also Mittelklasse-Clubs, kleine Clubs, wie man diese Abseits-Falle umspielen kann. Sie waren schon letztes Jahr entschlüsselt teilweise, konnten es aber auffangen, weil sie halt immer, ja dann schießen sie halt fünf, wenn sie zwei, drei kassieren. Jetzt konnten sie nicht immer fünf schießen, auch weil vorne viele Verletzungen, Rafinha verletzt, Ferran Torres war verletzt, ist jetzt zurück, Lewandowski war verletzt, ist jetzt zurück, Olmo habe ich schon erwähnt. Rashford ist ein neues Element, der macht das gut, aber im Gegenpressing ist er jetzt nicht so scharf wie ein Rafinha. Also du merkst schon, Max, viele, viele Gründe, die da zusammenspielen, Gegner, die es entschlüsselt haben und deswegen sieht es aktuell wirklich nach kamikaze aus, was Barca da unter Flick macht mit der Absatzfalle.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, drei Punkte Rückstand auf Real, Rang 2, erst zwei Niederlagen in der Liga. Also wir sprechen hier immer noch von einem sehr hohen Niveau.
Natürlich, aber du hast jetzt drei, drei gegen Brügge gespielt, die Art und Weise, wer das Spiel live gesehen hat. Oder vielleicht auch nur die Highlights. Sie reichen ja. Wir spielen leicht Brügge da durch die Abwehr, schneidet einfach nur mit Kontern, mit Gegenstößen, mit tiefen Läufen, dass das Brügge so leicht fällt. Girona, der Tabellenletzte, hätte vier Tore schießen können. Ich glaube, Barca hat das 3-1 gewonnen hinten raus. Ergebnis ist dann okay. Aber wenn du dir das Spiel anschaust, Girona, der eine, der wirklich die schwächste Mannschaft in der Liga ist, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, hätte vor der Halbzeit drei oder vier Tore schießen müssen. Das waren immer Riesenchancen. Das heißt, wenn du Chancen zulässt, sind das immer Eins-gegen-eins-Situationen oder riesige Chancen. Zwei gegen eins laufen, etc., etc. Also ultra viel XG, desto mehr spielst du mit einfach nur drei, vier Chancen, weil es so eine Kamikaze-Abseits-Linie ist, die eben ja strukturell ist. Eine strukturelle Geschichte mittlerweile ist. Gegner entschlüsseln das, was sie sehr schlau zum Beispiel machen. Der Gegner lässt den Stürmer im Abseits stehen. Im Zentrum kommt dann über außen ein Querpass vor das Tor und dann schiebt er ihn rein. Dieses Gegentor kassieren sie fast jede Woche, weil das eben eine strukturelle Sache ist, die jeder Gegner entschlüsselt hat, wie man eben diese Absetzfalle an der Mittellinie eben umspielen kann.
Und da sind wir natürlich beim entscheidenden Punkt, weil das eine sind eben Dinge, für die kann der Träger nichts. Eben die Größe des Kaders, die Verletzungen, Form, Schwäche und so weiter und so fort. Aber das andere, das Strukturelle, das ist ja was. Für das Hansi Flick dann was kann. Wie bewusst ist man sich denn in der spanischen Presse, wie so der deutsche Blick auf ihn ist, zumindest auf sein Spätwerk?
Ja, ich glaube, das hat man damals ausgeblendet oder gar nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt. Und das ist jetzt weiterhin so, er ist da nicht so im Zentrum der Kritik, sondern ich habe ja die Punkte genannt, Verletzungsmissere, dass sie Inigo Martinez verkaufen mussten etc. Das sind ja schon die Punkte, die man da noch heranführt. Wenn der Kader wieder voll und fit ist, können sie wieder diesen Fußball des letzten Jahres spielen, also einfach noch besser im Pressing sein, im Gegenpressing vorne noch schärfer. Und dann spielt es keine Rolle, dass du 1, 2 hinten kassierst, weil du so viel mehr Kohl spielst unten.
Aber können sie das wirklich sein? Denn wenn Uli vorhin sagt bei City, die wollen Pressing spielen wie Liverpool, aber die haben ja nur 40 Kilo-Spieler da vorne drin. Ich überspitze jetzt vielleicht ganz leicht. Also würde ich jetzt bei Barca auch nicht so komplett widersprechen, ehrlich gesagt. Und wir wissen ja, wie zum Beispiel Robert Lewandowski, wie richtig bock, wie scharf er einfach auf Anlaufen ist. Das ist so, ah, das war lieber als ein Torschuss.
Der hat jetzt bei Celta Vigo mit drei Toren wieder gerettet, also der alte Fuchs, weißt du noch, wo das Tor steht. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, Flick hat sich dazu geäußert und gesagt, sie wollen ja offensiv spielen, sie wollen ja attraktiv spielen, sie wollen ja Risiko eingehen. Das ist die DNA des FC Barcelona und damit trifft er natürlich den Nagel auf den Kopf. Deswegen will man ja offensiv spielen, das ist ja schon immer Barca gewesen. Deswegen sind sie ja nicht sauer, wenn sie 4-3 verlieren, eher gewinnen. Oder auch mal verlieren, gab es ja auch schon das Ergebnis, weil sie sagen, lieber so als irgendwie ein Gurken 1-0, bei dem wir auf der Tribüne gehen. Das gab es unter Xavi ja teilweise, der wirklich sehr konservativ hinten rausgespielt hat, unter Ernesto Valverde waren die Ergebnisse da. Der wäre ja fast ungeschlagen, hätte er die La Liga gewonnen, aber mit vielen 1-0-2-0-Siegen, wo sie nur verwaltet haben, aber hinten eben schlau genug waren, nicht in Konter zu laufen oder sich nicht ausspielen zu lassen. Also das ist immer so eine Sache. Dann gewinnen sie fast alles, aber das Publikum, die Medien unken trotzdem, weil das ist nicht unser Barca-Fußball. Und jetzt ist es halt zu sehr kamikaze Barca-Fußball. Aber das sehen sie Flick eher nach. Vor allem, er hat natürlich Kredit wegen letztem Jahres. Ist ja ganz klar. Sie hätten um ein Jahr das Trippel gewonnen. Das sollte man ja nicht vergessen. Sie waren die aufregendste Mannschaft Europas, die heißeste Mannschaft, die wirklich auch neutrale Fans begeistert. Wie im Fußball. Und dazu gehört ja eher ein 4-3-4-2 als ein 1-0-2-0.
Okay, klar, das stimmt natürlich auch. Ich will ja hier auch gar nicht irgendwie sagen, Hansi Flick muss gehen. Aber es ist halt interessant, weil es überrascht einen nicht komplett, wenn man sein Schaffen näher verfolgt hat, als es vielleicht manche getan haben, wohl wissend, dass er definitiv da nicht allein schuldig ist. Du hast ja die vielen anderen Faktoren genannt. Also schauen wir uns an, wie es bei Barca weitergeht. Ich glaube, das Champions League-Auswärtsspiel bei Chelsea, das könnte interessant werden Ende November.
Oh ja, ich weiß nicht, wie, da kann Uli dann vielleicht mal erklären, wie gut Chelsea so was entschlüsseln kann. Aber ich habe auch ein bisschen nicht Angst und Bange, aber das wird ein interessantes Spiel, sagen wir es mal so.
Man braucht keine Angst haben.
Da kommt wieder der alte Chelsea-Hate durch.
Die sind okay, machen ihr Zeug gut, aber das ist ein Team, das Barca schon schlagen müsste. Gerade wenn die defensive Personaldecke gerade so bestellt ist, bei Chelsea, wie es jetzt ist. Das ist ja immer mein Punkt gewesen, wenn man auch ein paar Mal zu Barca diskutiert, oder ich habe dich gefragt vielmehr. Und ich habe sie dann der Saison, glaube ich, drei, vier Mal gemacht. Mein Punkt bei Barca, die offensiv können die an jedem Tag, jedem Gegner drei bis acht reinlegen. Aber das Problem ist, dass sie gegen jeden Gegner viel zu viel Kraft aufwenden müssen, um Spiele zu gewinnen. Gegen jeden Gegner.
Gegen jeden.
Müssen sie doch ein paar mehr Spieler von Straßburg holen.
Ja.
Oh, dieses Thema, da freut man sich im Rasenfunk drüber.
Moment, ich habe die Connection gerade nicht verstanden. Was ist damit? Was war die Anspielung?
Straßburg und Chelsea, ne?
Ah so, Chelsea. Ich dachte, Barca soll Straßburgs Spieler holen.
Und ich dachte, was?
Mit welchem Geld? Für welchen Kader? Ach so, ja, gut, klar. Das ist ja, ja, da habe ich richtig Bock drauf. Auch wunderschön, dass das im Fußball der Frauen jetzt auch anfängt. Herzliche Grüße an Viktoria Berlin. Ja, ja.
Oh, ich habe nie mitbekommen.
Ja, da werden wir jetzt bestimmt viele Leihen aus der NWSL in die jetzt noch 2. Liga der Frauen sehen. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema und das kann man jetzt auch in der Kürze hier nicht mit rein pflegen. Also Uli hat uns gesagt, vor Chelsea muss man keine Angst haben. Wisst ihr, vor wem man in Europa auch keine Angst haben muss? Zumindest bis zum Trainerwechsel, den es jetzt gab. Ajax, Amsterdam. Daniel ist schon ganz heftig am Nicken. Er wusste, jetzt kommt er. Also wir haben das letzte Mal, Daniel, haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass Ajax wie ein Rätselheft am Bahnhof Kiosk ist. Also wie so ein Sudoku. Und die Frage war da noch offen, was passiert mit Trainer Heitinger. Jetzt wissen wir, okay, er ist Ex-Trainer von Ajax. Erzähle uns, was ist das neueste Amsterdam Update?
Ja, genau, es gibt viele Rätsel, gibt es auch immer noch um Ajax. Aber quasi diese Trainer-Entlassung war quasi das Naheliegendste und das kleinste Rätsel in den letzten Tagen und Wochen. Es war eigentlich schon absehbar, dass es passiert. Es war nicht nur die Frage, wann passiert es, weil ja auch der technische Direktor Alex Fuss hat ja seinen Verbleib dann auch nochmal geknüpft an Heitinger. Und in der Tat hat er gesagt, er ist jetzt auch weg. Hat aber auch auf Bitten von Ajax dem Blut gesagt, nee, ich bleibe jetzt doch noch ein paar Wochen, bis er einen Nachfolger gefunden hat. Ist auch eine Praxis, kann man so oder so sehen. Ich finde es ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber jetzt ist erstmal Alex Cruz noch auf Zeit im Amt, was auch die ganze Tretenersuche dann erschwert. Das komme ich gleich zu. Ich wollte aber nochmal sagen, dass 0 zu 3 in der Champions League jetzt gegen Istanbul, gegen Galatasaray und so weiter, quasi der Tropfen auf den Fass, der das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat, sozusagen rein sportlich gesehen, ist es auch überfällig, dass Heitinger endlich gehen musste. Also habe das Spiel gesehen. Ich konnte es unter großen Schmerzen dann auch ertragen. Es war ja offensiv eigentlich auf der Wahrungseite gar nichts. Also Gleiterserei hat dominiert, hat gedrückt und durch das Pressing von Istanbul kam mir die Offensiv-Riff von Ajax gar nicht zu trage. Und das ist eigentlich wieder eine weitere Geschichte, wo sich Heitinger ein bisschen vergriffen hat. Ich habe das schon öfters angezogen. Ich glaube, ich habe in der Saison im Rasenfunk noch nie so oft über Ajax gesprochen, hier im Rasenfunk, vielleicht in der letzten Saison. Und da muss ich auch nochmal dieses Partie von Marseille holen. Der hat sich auch verkaut, hat viel zu offensiv spielen lassen, jetzt viel zu defensiv und man hat das Gefühl, er hat einfach ein bisschen Pech und ein bisschen Unglück. Er findet nie wirklich den richtigen Zugriff auf jeweiligen Gegner und das muss man ihm dann schon vorwerfen. Das war jetzt gegen Istanbul auch so. Ich meine, in den letzten sieben Partien hat er einmal gewonnen, wettbewerbsübergreifend. Das war gegen Entrel, das war genau diese sieben Minuten, dieses Rätselheft, wo man auch nicht weiß, warum er gewonnen hat. Dieser Sieg ist auch sehr schmeichelhaft gewesen. Ansonsten stehen dann wirklich sehr grauenhafte Spiele zu Buche. Insofern ist es sportlich dann schon nachvollziehbar, dass er geht. Man war ja von ihm eh nicht so überzeugt. Es gab dann intern auch Stimmen, die sich am Anfang der Saison gegen aufgesprochen haben. Die hatten das wohl leider recht. Das ist schon eine neue Chance, die ich jetzt sehe, auch wenn ich kein Freund so bin von so schnell drinnen entlassen. Aber ich glaube, es ist für alle Italien besser, wie es gelaufen ist. Aber da Ajax Ajax ist, auch diesen Satz habe ich schon öfters gesagt, geht das Chaos ein bisschen weiter. Jetzt gab es Gerüchte um Erik Tenhaag, der war ja auch bei Twente im Stadion. Der war wirklich ein ernsthafter Kandidat. Der hat aber jetzt abgesagt, dem Club, und zwar mit der Begründung, dass Alex Cruz, der ja noch da ist, aber bald gehen wird, eben gehen wird. Der meinte halt, der Tenehaag hätte gerne mit Cruz zusammengearbeitet und da Cruz nicht bleibt, komme er nicht. Ja, und ich muss aber auch sagen, dass ich das für einen, ich will nicht sagen, Glücksfall für Ajax halte, aber ich glaube, dass es für den Club gut ist, dass Tenehaag nicht kommt.
Kommt die zwei, drei Wochen, Tenehaag hätte man schon auch noch überlebt.
Der hat sich ganz schön den Ruf ruiniert, ne?
Ja. Also, es wäre Ajax typisch, wenn er gekommen wäre, und es ist typisch, dass sie gefragt haben, dass sie ihn so etwas hatten. Aber ich glaube, das ist, du hast so eine große Fallhöhe erstmal. Du hast den Namen Tenehaag, der trotz dieses ruinierten Rufes eigentlich immer noch, vor allem in den Ligelanden, ein Riesenname ist.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, ne? Also wenn jemand, wenn in einem Land, der noch einen guten Ruf hat, dann ja vermutlich da, wo er tatsächlich bewiesen hat, ist er erfolgreich.
Ja, also es gibt nicht wenige Fans, die dieser Teraubrigste Tenehaag nicht kommt. Aber ich glaube halt, du kommst mit diesem großen Namen in den Ligelanden und mit dieser großen Fallhöhe, hast du sofort wieder einen medialen Druck auf den Feind, du hast sofort wieder hohe Erwartungen, die dieses Team in den nächsten paar Wochen nicht erfüllen kann. Ich glaube, mit keinem Trainer. Also da muss grundlegend an der Struktur noch ein bisschen gearbeitet werden, da muss grundlegend dieses Team erst mal neu orientiert werden. Das kann auch ein Tent H nicht in ein paar Wochen machen. Und wobei der Tent H noch ganz andere Probleme liegen, wenn die Zeit sich betrachtet, die Leverkusen es hatte. Dazu kommt, dass ein Tent H sicherlich teuer ist und teurer ist als andere Trainer auf dem Markt, die vielleicht keinen so großen Namen haben. Und man hat ja auch schon öfters gesagt, Ajax muss sparen und dann viel Geld für einen Star-Trainer auszugeben, der vielleicht nach fünf Wochen dann auch bei Ajax nicht mehr arbeitet und den man dann wieder zwei Jahre bezahlen muss, ist natürlich auch wirtschaftlich unsinnig. Und hinzu kommt eben, wenn du in Leverkusen nach dem dritten, zweiten Spieltag entlassen wirst als neuer Trainer, dann kann es nicht nur sportlich nicht gestimmt haben. Also es gibt ja da auch interne Gerüchte, die es ja wirklich wohl schwierig gewesen sei im Umgang. Also dieses Gesamtpaket bin ich schon froh, dass Ajax diesen Kelch quasi entgeht. Ich glaube, es hätte sie nicht so gut getan.
Wie nah Leverkusen daran war, einfach riesen Glück zu haben, dass sie dieses Gehalt nicht mehr weiterbezahlen müssen. Aber gut, es ist knapp vorbeigegangen. Aber weil du das selber auch schon so ein bisschen gesagt hast oder angefangen hast, es einzuordnen, wie findest du denn die Entscheidung mit Cruz, dem Sportdirektor, der sich eigentlich an den alten Trainer gekettet hatte, jetzt den neuen Trainer zu suchen? Denn bei allem, was wir jetzt, was ja auch ich an Witzen jetzt über Erik Ten Ha gemacht habe, aber ich kann das sehr gut verstehen, gerade auch vor dem Hintergrund, wie das aus seiner Perspektive jetzt in Leverkusen schnell zu Ende ging, dass er beim neuen Sportdirektor aber wissen will oder beim technischen Leiter, wie auch immer, der steht aber hinter mir.
Ja, das kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Ich kann den Haars-Premiergrund abzusagen nachvollziehen, weil die Trainerposition, die hat schon Priorität bei Ajax. Klar, sportliches Geschäft, laufendes Geschäft. Du hast jetzt die Länderspielpause, das ist ein bisschen zeitlichen Druck raus, aber du wirst ja schon erst mal den Trainer haben, bevor du dann den Posten von Cruz neu besetzt. Und das heißt, der Trainer wird höchstwahrscheinlich zuerst kommen.
Aber würde man es nicht eigentlich andersrum haben wollen, weil der sportliche Leiter ist doch der, der länger bleibt. In der Regel.
In der Regel, ja.
Gut, wir reden über Aya, das ist mir schon auch klar. Aber eigentlich würdest du doch sagen, wir brauchen erst einen sportlichen Leiter. Klar, als Trainer ist es wichtiger, weil du brauchst jemanden, der das Training macht. Aber dann nimm halt irgendeinen Interim-Coach. Irgendein niederländischer Eugen Polanski wird sich schon finden. Und wer weiß, vielleicht ist er der niederländische Eugen Polanski. Und dann hast du sogar deinen neuen Trainer gefunden.
Ja, also sie hatten jetzt gegen Gültrecht einen Interim-Coach, der hat 2-1 verloren und hat eigentlich das Friedrich Trimm. Ja, der tut mir auch ein bisschen leid, der kann ja jetzt auch nicht so viel dafür. Er hat gegen Gültrecht jetzt am Wochenende auch nichts verändert. Groß und deswegen hat sich am Ergebnis auch nichts verändert. Groß und 2-1 verloren mit einer ähnlichen Leistung wie Nutter Eitinga, mit dem selben 4-2-3-1-System, was Ajax ja auch nicht traditionell eigentlich nicht spielt. Ja, ich verstehe den Punkt. Es gibt auch Überlegungen, Ajax ist ein Interim-Coach, sich zu holen. Wobei ich dann denke, ja gut, dann hast du irgendwie ein halbes Jahr jetzt vielleicht ein und im nächsten, nächste Saison wird er wieder neu gesucht. Ja, ich kann beide Versionen verstehen. Bei Ajax ist es jetzt jedenfalls so, dass sie diesen Trainer-Post priorisiert haben. Ich glaube, auch wegen des letzten Spiels Paulus. Jetzt sagen wir, jetzt haben wir die Zeit und dann können wir den Trainer jetzt schnell finden. Hat ja halt noch eine Woche mehr oder ein paar Tage mehr bis zum nächsten Ligaspiel. Ich glaube, das ist auch so der Punkt, warum sie jetzt so schnell auf dieser Suche sind.
Und gehe ich recht in der Annahme, dass auf dem Flipchart, wo draufsteht, Kriterien für unseren neuen Trainer, also auf Niederländisch natürlich, dass da draufsteht, muss in der Bundesliga in dieser Saison entlassen worden sein. Und wir deswegen über Paulus Simonis sprechen, der mit Wolfsburg wirklich Außergewöhnliches geleistet hat.
Ja, das ist, es mutet so an, ja. Ich glaube, auf der Flipchart steht vor allem, günstig, verfügbar und Niederländischen. Das trifft ja auf ihn relativ zu und ich mir sicher, vor allem günstig. Ja, ich hatte mir das Spiel, sein letztes Spiel in Bremen auch angesehen.
Oh Gott, Daniel, was tust du?
Ja, ich wollte mal ein bisschen Simone-Scouting machen. Nein, und...
Das kommt ja im Rasenfunk dazu hier, oder? Dass sich Menschen, dass Gäste schlimme Spiele anschauen müssen für dich, Max. Also...
Ja, okay, das stimmt. Okay, fair. Eigentlich nicht in diesem Format, aber okay.
Ja, aber das war quasi eine Parallele zu dem Champions-League-Spiel von Ajax gegen Gala Sarey mit den Rollen, dass Ajax dann das Wolfsburg war und Gala Sarey dann Werder. Von den Spielanteilen her und vom Dominanz her und vom Verlauf her. Nur, dass Wolfsburg noch blau gemacht hat, was Ajax gegen Gala nicht gemacht hat. Und das ist ja eigentlich genau der Art von Fußball, der jetzt in den letzten Spielen unter Heitinka stattgefunden hat und den man ja eigentlich nicht mehr möchte. Deswegen bin ich bei Simonis auch eher skeptisch. Kann mir aber vorstellen, dass er kommt, tatsächlich weil er eben verfügbar ist, weil er die Liga kennt, weil er auch noch Erfolg bei den Go-Head Eagles hatte mit dem Wetter. Kann ich mir so auch vorstellen, dass dann gesagt wird, naja gut, wir geben dir in der RID Vizier nochmal eine Chance. Ich hoffe nur mit anderen praktischen Ansatz. Weil die sind ja sehr defensiv, sehr zurückhaltend. Und offensiv kann man von Wurzburg ja auch trotz dieses, wie ich finde, gar nicht mal so schlechten Offensiv-Kaders, gar nichts. So und das erinnert mich eigentlich genau an Hatingo und Ajax. Insofern, ja, ich kann mir mal vorstellen, dass er kommt. Vielleicht funktioniert das. Es ist so ein bisschen Prinzip Glück, glaube ich, was Ajax auch macht. Nach dem Motto, irgendwer wird es, wenn wir genug Leute rotieren lassen, wenn wir genug Leute vertreten, das wird schon klappen. Ja, das kann sein, muss aber auch nicht sein. Ja, das wird auf jeden Fall spannend. Was ich gehört habe, ist, dass Simonis in der Tat ein ernsthafter Kandidat ist. Was ich noch sagen muss, was mich auch entsetzt hat, das ist auch wieder der Entscheidung, die ich nicht verstehen kann. Es wird parallel, weil Cruz eben geht, auch da nach dem Nachfolger schon ge- verhandelt. Und Mark Overmars, der war schon mal bei Ajax Sächsischer Direktor, und der wurde 2022 entlassen. Aufgrund von der offiziellen Mitteilung hieß das grenzüberschreitendes Verhalten. Das waren wohl Dickpicks, die er verschickt hat. Der wurde deswegen dann auch gekündigt, zurecht. Und bei dem habt ihr jetzt angefragt, ob der nicht wieder Lust hätte. Ist ihr jetzt auch schon drei Jahre vergangen. Ja, könnte man, ist ja schon krass zu mal gewachsen über die Sache. Hast du ja nicht mal wieder Lust, bei uns zu arbeiten? Und er hat abgelegt. Und allein die Tatsache, dass Ajax da ernsthaft anfragt, ist eigentlich schon offenbarungseid und moralisch, ethisch ganz schwierig. Und da sagt er auch noch ab. Also das ist in der Führungsebene abseits. Das ist bei Ajax alles sehr, sehr schwierig. Und ich kann nur hoffen, dass die beiden, die jetzt kommen, wer immer es noch sein mag, das diesmal schaffen, ein bisschen Ruhe reinzubringen. Das würde ich sehr wünschen.
Also, ist du vielleicht– also ich verstehe den Formwunsch, Daniel. Aber alles, was du uns gerade erzählt hast, sagt eindeutig, wir werden noch tausendmal über Ajax sprechen der Saison. Es wird einfach alles fürchterlich bleiben. Also, ich bin gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Okay, das ist die aktuelle Situation bei Ajax. Es ist ja fast schon zweiwöchentliches Update, was wir hier draus machen. So ehrlich muss man sein. Wir haben in einer Liga immer noch nicht geblickt, deswegen ist höchste Zeit, dass Christian jetzt mal zu Wort kommen darf. Und, Christian, du hast uns jemand mitgebracht, der bisher auch so ein bisschen sträflich vernachlässigt wurde in der Ligatur. Ich weiß nicht genau, vielleicht weil man Milan noch nicht so ganz getraut hat. Erzähl uns mal, was ist da gerade los?
Also, anhängend zu Ajax vor Milan muss man in dieser Saison auch keine Angst haben. Das liegt darin in Europa, dass die in Europa nicht spielen. Und das vielleicht ist der Grund, warum man aber vor ihnen in Italien ein bisschen Angst haben sollte. Denn letztes Jahr Katastrophensaison, erinnern sich vielleicht noch ein paar, Konzessau von Seca, zwei portugiesische Trainer verbrannt, die europäischen Plätze verpasst. Und dann kam im Sommer Iglitare als neuer Sportdirektor, auch wieder einer mit viel Erfahrung. Vielleicht nicht einer, der immer im Scheinwerferlicht steht, aber der bei Lazio jahrelang sehr gute Arbeit gemacht hat. Und mit Max Allegri, neuer Trainer, der bei Juve logischerweise in den Jahren zuvor jetzt auch nicht geglänzt hat, aber der sich bei Milan sehr schnell eingefunden hat. Und man hatte schon nach wenigen Spielen so ein bisschen das Gefühl, es passt, Allegri und Milan, das passt. Allegri zur Erinnerung war ja 2011 auch der Meistertrainer bei Milan, also er kennt das Umfeld. Und ja, jetzt ist es so, Milan nach elf Spieltagen sind sie nur zwei Punkte hinter der Tabellenspitze. Und man kann sagen, hätten sogar am Wochenende, die haben jetzt 2-2 ein paar Mal gespielt, nach 2-0-Führung müssen sie eigentlich gewinnen. Dann wären sie sogar punktgleich auf eins. Das ist ja sehr, sehr kuschelig in der Serie A. Das sind, glaube ich, die ersten fünf Teams innerhalb von zwei Punkten. Also sehr eng da alles. Und ja, ich glaube, es macht Sinn, mal kurz auf Milan zu schauen, warum das in dieser Saison ganz gut läuft bisher.
Und kann man dem Ganzen aber auch langfristig trauen? Weil die Ergebnisse sind natürlich insofern gut, dass man erst einmal verloren hat, gleich am ersten Spieltag. Und das haben noch manche mitbekommen, weil das war gegen Kremonese zu Hause. Da haben wir auch, glaube ich, ganz kurz drüber gesprochen. Ich weiß immer nicht, ob es in der Sendung gelandet ist. Ehrlich gesagt. Aber es waren ja jetzt auch viele Unentschieden zuletzt, die man mit dabei hatte. Also 0 zu 0 gegen Juve, 2 zu 2 gegen Pisa, 1 zu 1 gegen Atalanta und jetzt eben dieses 2 zu 2 gegen Parma ist ja vor dem Hintergrund dann nicht ganz so überraschend gewesen.
Das stimmt, genau. Also du sprichst ja schon an. Gerade sage ich mal die Unentschieden gegen die kleineren. Die sind ein bisschen auffällig. 2 zu 2 gegen Parma, 2 zu 2 zu Hause gegen Pisa-Aufsteiger, dann die Heimniederlage zum Auftakt gegen Kremonese. Aber das liegt schon lange zurück. Da waren wir im August. Ja, dem kann man aber halt entgegenhalten. Allegri Milan hat halt Napoli geschlagen, den Meister. Allegri Milan hat die Roma geschlagen, die er auch auf Platz 1 im Moment ist. Und sie haben auswärts bei Juve 0-0 gespielt, also einen Punkt geholt in Turin. Dementsprechend ist es logischerweise in keinster Weise perfekt. Darum geht es nicht. Aber man sieht schon vieles, was Allegri ganz gut eingearbeitet hat. Er hat logischerweise angefangen, die Defensive zu stabilisieren. Das war ja letztes Jahr ein Vogelwild, was darunter von Seca und Konza Saur, ich nenne es mal unter Anführungszeichen, verteidigt wurde. Da ist jetzt einfach mit dieser Rückkehr zur Dreierkette. Da fühlen sich gerade Pavlovic, der Ex-Salzburger und Tomori richtig wohl. Das tut denen richtig gut. Gerade Pavlovic sticht da raus, hat auch schon zwei Tore erzielt. Dem tut das einfach richtig gut. Dann hast du logisch mit Luka Modrić, das müssen wir jetzt schon auch mal nennen. Der ist ja dann auch noch nicht gefallen. Milan hat ja Modrić geholt. Und Milan hat, ich würde sagen, aus Modrić Sicht den perfekten Zeitpunkt. Denn dadurch, dass Milan eben nicht europäisch spielt, hat er immer nur ein Spiel pro Woche. Das heißt, er spielt am Samstag oder Sonntag, hat dann die ganze Woche Zeit, sich zu regenerieren. Hat bis jetzt jedes Spiel von Anfang an gespielt, auch fast alle Spiele über die ganze komplette Distanz. Und der gibt dir logisch in Sachen Ordnung und Spielrhythmus schon das, was Jan-Lukas Modrić geben kann. Auch wenn er 40 Jahre alt ist, aber das hat er halt einfach drauf. Daneben hat er mit Rabiot und Fofona zwei Laufstärke, zwei dynamische Achter, die sowohl mit Ball als auch gegen Ball ihm da auch oft den Rücken frei halten. Und das Spannendste ist eigentlich die Rolle von Leao, die Allegri ihm schon im Sommer sozusagen neu mitgegeben hat. Also er hat Leao vom Flügel weggezogen, wirklich ins Zentrum rein. Also er setzt jetzt auf den 3-5-2. Im Prinzip ist Leao einer oder zwei, unter Anführungszeichen, Mittelstürmer. Also klar, er setzt keine klassischen Neuen, aber sein Radius ist viel zentraler. Man merkt auch, er macht auch immer wieder. Man sieht auch schon wirklich Neuner-Elemente in seinem Spiel. Also hin und wieder macht er auch mal einen Ball mit dem Rücken zum Tor fest. Er hat ja auch eine gewisse Physik, die er mitbringt. Also macht er wirklich durchlebt, als so eine gewisse Metamorphose. Und logischerweise, wenn Leao Raum vor sich hat, und das passiert unter Allegri immer noch ganz gerne, denn Allegri hat kein Problem damit, auch mal tiefer zu stehen, sozusagen den Raum für den Gegner eingemacht zu machen, um dann eben umzuschalten. Und da ist logischerweise Leao– ja, in Europa, glaube ich, gibt es nicht so viele, die diese Qualität haben. Und deswegen ist es schon ganz spannend, dass er vieles schon richtig auf den Weg gebracht hat. Also man sieht sich, die Mannschaft fühlt sich wohl. In dem, was sie machen, gerade das Barma-Spiel muss man jetzt wirklich ausklammern, die führen 2-0, stellen dann 30 Minuten in den Spielbetrieb ein und kassieren das 2-2, hätten hinten raus aber noch zwei Riesenchancen mit Publis, mit Zahlenmarkers, könnten sie auch noch gewinnen. Also diese, ich sage mal, dass sie sich manchmal den Gegner ein bisschen tief wieder in den eigenen Strafraum reinholen, das ist so ein bisschen Allegri-Ding, das kennen wir auch aus den vergangenen Jahren, da muss er vielleicht schon auch noch ein bisschen leichte Anpassungen machen, aber vom Prinzip her hat man schon nach wenigen Spielen gemerkt, okay, das ist eine Allegri-Mannschaft, die fühlen sich wohl. Salenmarkers auf der rechten Schiene, funktioniert wunderbar, hat das letztes Jahr bei der Roma auch schon gespielt. Und Christian Pulisic, der hat jetzt wochenlang verletzt gefehlt, der hatte einen herausragenden Saisonstart, war ja eigentlich die letzten Jahre, auch die schwierigen Milan-Jahre, eigentlich die Konstanz in Person. Klar, letztes Jahr war rein, dass der, der vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr rausgestochen hat, aber Pulisic hat immer geliefert, trifft, liefert Vorlagen. Und auch ohne Pulisic sind sie jetzt halt weiterhin ganz vorne da dabei geblieben. Pulisic kam jetzt eben ein paar Mal zurück. Und ich glaube, dass sich da über lang oder kurz dieses Duo Leao und Pulisic da vorne im Stuppen sozusagen etablieren wird. Dann spielst du ohne wirklichen Neuner, aber halt mit einem sehr Spielintelligenten wie Pulisic und einem mit extremen Tempo wie Leao. Und das scheint schon alles sehr harmonisch zu sein.
Also da hätte ich null Euro drauf gewettet, dass das neue Sturm Duo Leao und Pulisic ist in dieser Saison. Aber okay, so entwickelt sich. Du bist natürlich auch bekannt als Allegri-Versteher. Ich glaube, Mario hat das mal über dich gesagt, irgendwann der Ligatour. Wirst du denn dementsprechend jetzt dann auch ein nicht überrascht sein, wenn man gegen Inter gewinnt? Denn das ist ja das nächste Top-Spiel, das ansteht für Milan jetzt am Wochenende.
Ja, wie gesagt, die Top-Spiel-Statistik, die passt erst mal in der Saison. Napoli geschlagen, Roma geschlagen, Juwe auswärts einen Punkt geholt. Ob ich in Allegri-Versteher bin, ist eigentlich relativ egal. Aber ich sage mal so, ich traue Milan wirklich zu, bis ganz zum Schluss, ganz ganz vorne mit dabei zu sein. Aus unterschiedlichen Gründen. Napoli hat ja so einige Themen. Das merkt man, die Doppelbelastung unter Konter. Das ist ein Thema. Inter ist logischerweise hat sich jetzt wieder gefangen. Aber auch Inter hat die Doppelbelastung und Milan, das ist einfach mein Hauptgrund, habe ich auch schon im Sommer gesagt. Ich glaube, in der heutigen Zeit mit so vielen Spielen, mit dieser hohen Intensität, wenn du als Top-Team das Einzige bist, das Sonntag, Sonntag, Samstag spielt, ohne am Dienstag, Mittwoch oder Donnerstag quer durch Europa zu reisen, dann ist das, glaube ich, ein Riesen-Plus. Und Allegri ist da früh in den Modus reingefunden. Wie gesagt, hat die Mannschaft hinter sich. Es ist wirklich Pavlovic ganz interessant. Immer wenn Leao startet, startet Pavlovic auch mit. Weil zum Beispiel gegen die Roma macht er das Tor. Also wirklich die Kontern. Und während Leao startet, startet auch schon Pavlovic aus der Dreierkette. Also der hat wirklich so ein bisschen die, wie soll man sagen, die Lizenz, sich ganz vorne mit seiner Wucht auch mit reinzubringen. Und wie gesagt, das sind viele Mechanismen, die passen. Und ich glaube einfach, dieser Vorteil, einmal pro Woche zu spielen, der wird sich auszahlen über kurz oder lang. Und deswegen, mich wird es in keinster Weise überraschen, wenn wir mit Frühling noch mal darüber reden, dass Milan immer noch mitten im Meisterrennen ist. Weil eben, über Ménián haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen. Sie haben Ménián ja immer noch einen, ja, glaube ich, wenn er in Form ist, der stärkeren Torhüter Europas. Jiménez, der Stürmer, der Mexikaner, der hat zwar noch nicht getroffen, hat aber, arbeitet sehr viel gegen den Ball. Also lange hat Jiménez auch jedes Spiel bestritten. Der ist ja noch so ein bisschen neuner. Der hat zwar noch nicht eben sein Knipsergehen gefunden, aber der ist halt wahnsinnig fleißig im Spiel gegen den Ball. Guter Pressing-Stürmer, der läuft ja Löcher zu. Und den hat der Ligue auch immer wieder vertraut. Jede Woche kam er, der trifft nicht, der trifft nicht. Und der Ligue meinte, ja, aber schaut euch halt bitte mal an, was er für den Rest des Spiels beiträgt. Und deswegen, wie gesagt, ist das harmonisch. Modrić hat sich wunderbar eingelebt. Und letzter Satz noch. Die letzten Unentschieden, Max, die du angesprochen hast, sind ja relativ viele. Sind alle gekommen, als Rabiot gefehlt hat. Ich glaube, mit Rabiot hatten sie einen Punkteschnitt von 2,5. Also fast alles gewonnen. Und ohne Rabiot ist es mindestens einen Punkt weniger. Also Rabiot ist wirklich extrem, wirklich wichtig für die Balance dieser Mannschaft. Der tut eben Modrić gut. Der tut Fafná auch gut. Fafná ist so ein bisschen, ja, ich sag mal, der hat schon immer wieder einen kleinen Lapsus drin. Aber Rabiot, mit seiner Erfahrung, mit seiner Dynamik, kennt Allegri ja in- und auswendig schon von seinen Juwelzeiten. Und Rabiot kommt jetzt nach der Länderspielpause wieder. Also jetzt mit Rabiot und Pjulisic, glaube ich. Also wenn die alle fit sind, ja, mit Milan ist zu rechnen.
Das haben sie ja alles Rennen zu verdanken, dass Rabiot überhaupt da gelandet ist. Nee, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht.
Ja, oder Herrn Rowe auch zu verdanken.
Auch das, ja, genau.
Ja, sehr gut. Alle Wege führen nach Rennen. Wer kennt es nicht? Das alte Wort.
Vor allem in Italien.
Genau. Und dass Luca Modric da wirklich, ich hatte schon mitbekommen, dass er eine wichtige Rolle spielt, aber dass der wirklich in jedem Spiel in der Startelle stand und bis auf 27 Minuten jede Minute bisher gespielt hat, mit 40 Jahren und 65 Tagen stand der Aufnahme.
Nur ein Satz noch dazu. Ich weiß, da war Modric jetzt 14, jetzt ist er in der Serie A. Ich habe mir extra rausgesucht, wie viel der Spieler letztes Jahr für Real gemacht hat. Schätzt mal, wie viel der letzte Saison Pflichtspieler für Real gemacht hat.
Fast alle.
Genau. Danke Uli. Der hat 60 Pflichtspiele gemacht. Klar, sehr viele, nur Kurzeinsätze. Aber wer bei Real im Alter von 39, weil Werde hat ein oder zwei Spiele mehr gemacht, dann war schon Modric mit der Anzahl der Spiele, hat jedes Champions-League-Spiel für Real gemacht, hat, glaube ich, 35 von 36 Ligaspielen gemacht. Ja, die Minutenanzahl war reduziert, aber wer so eine Rolle bei Real spielt, kann auch bei Milan noch mit 40. Sehr gut.
Ganz offensichtlich. Also, das ist die Situation in Milan. Dann gehen wir mal noch ein bisschen kürzer durch die Ligen durch. David Verdomaxen, darfst du uns noch ein zweites Thema hier kurz vorführen? Was gibt es hier noch aus der Liga anzuberichten?
Ja, ich dachte mir, wenn ich jetzt schon tatsächlich mal vor Ort war und zufälligerweise eben im Stadion war vergangene Woche, dann reden wir noch mal über Netzer. Da können wir übrigens gleich noch über den nächsten über 40-Jährigen sprechen, weil Dante hat ja letzte Saison über 2000 Spielminuten gemacht mit 41 und ist jetzt 42 geworden dieses Jahr. Und ich fange mal ganz kurz mit dem Trainer an, mit Frank Aes. Ich glaube, der Name ist ein paar Mal gefallen in den letzten Rasenfunkjahren, aber ich erwarte jetzt von den Hörern auch nicht unbedingt, dass sie sich da so, also nicht alle zumindest in der Liga auskennen, ständig und so weiter und so weiter. Der Durchbruch von Aes kam 2020 mit Lens. Da hat er aus begrenzten Möglichkeiten sehr viel gehabt, viel gemacht, hat so eine Einheit geformt, Pressungsystem installiert und kam dann eben 2024 nach Nizza mit dem Gefühl, er soll ihnen den letzten Push jetzt verleihen, um sie wirklich auch mal in der Spitze zu etablieren. Und er kam da vergangene Saison zu einem Team, das war durchaus talentiert, aber das hat nicht so gut zusammen gearbeitet und eigentlich auf seinen Stil nicht so gut gepasst mit Pressing und Einheit und defensiver Stabilität. Da hat er sein System also angepasst, hat erstmal dann Leute zurückgezogen, defensive Spieler, Mittelfeldspieler zurückgezogen, Außenverhaltiger nicht ganz so weit vorlaufen lassen, um da irgendwie das defensive Gerüst reinzubekommen. Und dann war jetzt so die Erwartung, naja, also nachdem er jetzt diese Saison da, das so etabliert hat, kann er ja jetzt diese Saison mal drauf aufbauen und da ein bisschen einen Schritt vorangehen. Und das funktionierte aber unter anderem in Europa seit Saisonbegehren absolut überhaupt gar nicht. Kann man jetzt sagen, naja, vielleicht sind in Europa viel, viel mehr Mannschaften auch dieses hohe Pressing gewohnt und auch diese Intensität. Absolut verheerende Bilanz für Nizze in Europa. Haben jetzt auch in Europa League alle vier Spiele verloren, unter anderem jetzt auch gegen den SC am Donnerstag. Und ich muss sagen, phasenweise hat Freiburg da jetzt auch wirklich nicht die Sterne von Himmel gespielt. Und in der Liga war es ähnlich. Da war der Saisonstart so ein bisschen holprig. Skapur, Niederlagen gegen Leavre und Brest. Das sind jetzt auch nicht die Top-Player der Liga diese Saison. Dann aber gab es so eine großartige Serie mit Siegen gegen Rennes, gegen Lille, gegen Lyon, gute Spiele gegen Monaco und PSG. Und dann kam dieses Freiburg-Spiel. Und in Freiburg kann man noch sagen, na ja, das war so eine Aneinanderreihung an individuellen Fehlern. Gegen Metz jetzt am Wochenende war es aber ein Totalversagen. Und Metz tauchte auch schon hier auf im Rasenfunk. Da hatte Jakob genau erzählt, dass die eigentlich also direkt wieder absteigen, dass es denen gar nicht gut geht. Plot twist, die haben jetzt drei Spiele in Folge gewonnen.
Seitdem, seit dieser Aufnahme. Als sie immer noch sichtlos waren.
Genau, ja. Und zwar alle relativ spät. So in den letzten Minuten spekuliert man schon über eine Minion-Time. Wegen des Trainers Le Minion. Und ja, genau. Also, Ers hat nach dem SC-Spiel eine absolut wütende Brandrede losgelassen. Er hat den Charakter der Spieler kritisiert. Er hat, die würden sich zu schnell fallen lassen. Die hätten die Basics nicht verinnerlicht. Die müssten immer 110 Prozent geben. 90 Prozent reichen nicht. Hat mich teilweise fast an Streichelände, muss ich sagen. Und das fand ein sehr großes Echo in den Medien tatsächlich, in den französischen, weil das ist man für ihn nicht ganz so gewohnt. Der ist gilt eigentlich eher als als ruhiger, überlegter, sehr sympathischer Trainer. Man wusste auch nicht gar nicht so genau, was ist das jetzt? Ist das ein ist das ist das Wut oder ist das so ein Hilferuf von? Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich hier machen soll mit den Jungs. Also auch da wieder so dieses, was wir vorhin auch hatten. Jemand möchte ein ein intensives System spielen, aber die hat nicht die hat nicht die richtigen Spieler dazu. Und das das das stimmt auch. Im Fehlen auch so ein paar da ein oder andere, der eben mal bei schlechterem Spielverlauf ein Team führen kann, unter anderem eben Dante tatsächlich. Also der jetzt auch schon seit zehn Jahren bei bei Nizza ist und eben eigentlich immer noch Kapitän und sie haben aktuell keinen Kapitän. Also Grüße an der Stelle an die Kollegen vom vom Sportcast dieses Spiel von Freiburg besprochen haben und sich gewundert haben, wieso hat denn dieser Bart da in der in der in der Verteidigung die Kapitänsbinde getragen mit seinen riesigen Fehlern, die er da zugelassen hat. Ja, weil es gibt keinen Kapitän gerade. Also die Kapitänsbinde wechselt. Zuletzt war es von Hute, der Belgier, der kam aber erst im Sommer. Dann war es auch mal Torwart Diouf, der kam auch erst im Sommer. Also wenn Leute Kapitänsbinden tragen, der erst seit vier Monaten da sind, merkst du schon, ok, irgendwas stimmt da irgendwie gerade nicht. Und ja, es fragt sich jetzt öffentlich, na ja, ist mein System doch zu ambitioniert? Müssen wir wieder zurück? Müssen wir wieder widerspielen? Aber das sollte das ja eigentlich nicht sein. Das sollte ja eigentlich eine Weiterentwicklung sein. Und ihr wirkt da so ein bisschen erschöpft und emotional und ratlos. Also da ist richtig Trouble drin. Und ja, also man fragt sich, was passiert jetzt? Ein paar Sommertransfers haben auch nicht gezündet. Auch dann an der Stelle wieder ganz interessant, weil das geht dann in Richtung Sportdirektion natürlich. Und Sportdirektion ist aktuell Florian Maurice. Der kam aber selbst auch erst vergangenes Jahr. Der hat ebenfalls den Ruf eines absolut perfekten Kaderplaners. Der hat in Lyon und in Rennes wohl gemerkt, hat ja großartige Jahre gehabt, war verantwortlich dafür, dass Rennes, ich sage mal, vierter wurde und sich da stabilisiert hat. Aber gut, auch da vielleicht liegt es wieder eben daran, vielleicht hat er gute Spieler geholt, aber die passen halt nicht ganz zum System des Trainers. Und das wird jetzt sehr spannend, weil nach der Länderspielpause steht das Derby an gegen Marseille. Am 21. November. Da wird dann auch das Stadion definitiv voll sein im Gegensatz zum Spiel gegen Freiburg. Das war ja ein Armutszeugnis. Wobei Marseille-Fans werden nicht da sein, weil die Behörden haben direkt vor der Reise schon mal angekündigt, nein, wir verbieten die Auswärtsreise. Mit sehr merkwürdigen Begründungen, unter anderem Erinnerungen daran, dass ja damals vor ein paar Jahren Nizza-Fans Marseille-Spieler angegriffen haben, wo man sich fragt, okay, aber wenn Nizza-Fans Marseille-Spieler angreifen, warum dürfen dann Marseille-Fans nicht nach Nizza? Also das ist nach wie vor ein problematisches Thema mit Behörden, Polizei und Auswärtsreisenden in Frankreich.
Hat ja auch der SC erfahren, das kann man bei 3.90 bei dir noch mal nachhören. Da hast du da ja auch drüber gesprochen.
Genau, genau, genau, genau. Und das liegt unter anderem daran, dass die Präffekten relativ viel Macht haben. Und die Präffekten sind anders, als wir jetzt in Deutschland halt vielleicht so im Kopf gewohnt sind. Das ist ja keine föderale Regierung. Die sind direkt dem Innenminister unterstellt. Das ist quasi eine zentralistische Institution und die kann ohne gerichtliche Beschlüsse, kann die beschließen, ja, da könnte was schwierig werden, wir verbieten das. Ich sage, das dürfen sie seit einem Gesetz, also sie dürfen es auch schon vorher ein bisschen, aber es wurde nochmal verstärkt durch ein Gesetz von 2011, das heißt LOPSI DEUX, wunderschöner Name, damals unter Sarkozy und das war ein umfassendes Gesetz zur Sicherheit. Es ging auch um Videoüberwachung und Digitalqualität und so weiter, also nicht nur um Sport, aber es gab einem eben auch einen Teil im Sport, der beschäftigte sich mit Gewalt rund um Sportereignisse, Klammer auf, Insert Football hier, Klammer zu. Das war sicherlich damals auch beeinflusst von den Ausschreitungen da in Paris, den Ultrakämpfen, wo ja auch tragischerweise ein persönliches Leben gekommen ist und eben auch im Vorgriff auf die EM. Aber da wurden tatsächlich sehr, sehr weitreichende Maßnahmen den Behörden an die Hand gegeben und die werden in den letzten Jahren immer stärker genutzt. Und das ist halt dann alles auch rechtlich und im Service-Fall sagt man sich halt, naja gut, ich hab das Gefühl, da sind Probleme, dann mach ich aber im Vorfeld schon mal den Laden dicht, dann kommen die Probleme erst gar nicht. Das ist natürlich alles höchst tragisch.
Absolut. Und da wird uns in Deutschland auch noch einiges blühen. Am 3. Dezember ist die Innenministerkonferenz, die inoffizielle, auf der auch weitere Maßnahmen gegen Fußballfans beschlossen werden sollen. Und das, obwohl sogar die eigenen hinterfragbaren Zahlen sagen, dass es sicherer geworden ist in deutschen Stadien in der letzten Saison. Aber das ist noch mal ein ganz eigenes Thema. Mal gucken, wann das mal wieder im Rasenfunk stattfindet. Also, Nizza gegen Marseille am 21. November. Das kann man sich mal zu Gemüte führen. Und dann werden wir sehen, ob es da jetzt in ruhigere Fahrwasser geht. Meine Erwartungshaltung– naja, wir werden nochmal sehen. Ja, genau. Spoilern, nein. Aber das tut es ja nie. Deswegen ist ja Fußball auch so schön zum Drüber sprechen. In etwas ruhigere Fahrwasser ist aber jetzt United gekommen. Und Uli, da müssen wir jetzt mal kurz drüber sprechen, weil United hat hier seit im Grunde Einführung der Ligatur immer nur negative Schlagzeilen gemacht in diesem Format. Und jetzt aber läuft es mal kurzzeitig zumindest besser?
Ja, nie besser. Also zu Ligaturzeiten nie besser zu Amorimzeiten. Fünf in Folge jetzt ohne Niederlage. Wir müssen ja nicht mehr alle Wettbewerbe dazu sagen, weil sie später nur noch einen spielen. Daher ist das relativ schnell erzählt. Auch wenn es jetzt zwei unentschiedene Folgen waren, jeweils mit zwei Gegentoren. Der Oktober war schon insgesamt gut. Hat auch den Manager des Monats– auch das hätte ich never ever gedacht, dass ich das noch mal sage– Rufem Amorim hervorgebracht. Den Spieler des Monats haben sie ja auch gestellt, mit Brian Mböhmow. Und damit ist es natürlich schon ein Name genannt, an dem das zu großen Teilen liegt. Aber im Ernst, also ich habe mir das jetzt noch mal, ich muss ja immer versuchen, das zu erklären, woran es liegt, dass es jetzt besser geworden ist. Und das ist okay, was die gerade machen. Also wenn das, auch das muss man noch mal einordnend dazu sagen. Ich bin deshalb glücklich damit, was gerade passiert, weil es natürlich vorher so bodenlos war, dass im Grunde alles eine kleine Verbesserung ist. Nichts desto weniger ist das okay im Moment. Wäre es das gewesen, womit Amorim von Beginn an aufgefahren wäre, dann wären wir alle einigermaßen einverstanden damit.
Aber wie spielt denn United? Das eine sind die Ergebnisse, das andere ist, wie sie zustande kommen.
Im Grunde ist das System, das hat er ja auch so vorhergesagt, immer noch das Gleiche, aber es ist schon in der Art und Weise ein bisschen anders geworden. Es gibt ein paar Hauptthemen. Zum einen sind sie ein bisschen direkter geworden. Das heißt, sie haben nicht mehr so viel nutzlosen Ballbesitz im eigenen 16er. Sie haben viel, viel hintenrum über diese 5er-Gette gespielt. Und jetzt haben die meisten Spielwechsel innerhalb der Premier League. Womit man ja schon sehen kann, es geht viel auf diagonal. Dann würde ich sagen, sind die Neuzugänge mitverantwortlich, dass das einigermaßen gut funktioniert. Also ein Beumot vor allen Dingen, weil das jemand ist, der diese Diagonalbälle gut aufnehmen kann. Breite hält, super erster Kontakt zum Tor zieht und so weiter. Lemmens im Tor, sehr gut, spielt viel, viel mehr lange Bälle, als Beye das vorher gemacht hat, der sehr kurz oft gespielt hat. Und United hat immer noch die meisten Torhüterballberührungen in der Premier League. Das heißt, das tut gut. Dann kommt Cesko auch ins Spiel, der mir viel zu schlecht wegkommt, insgesamt, auch wenn die Zahlen jetzt noch nicht so richtig gut sind, was das Torrischsten erzählt. Aber allein dieser eine lange Ball von Lemmens in Richtung Cesko kann vieles zum Positiven verändern. Sie haben so ein Mini-Workaround gefunden für Casemiro und Bruno. Bruno ist jetzt so leicht nach hinten gefallen in Systemen, dass er eigentlich nicht passt. Es ist auch immer noch so. Genau das Gleiche ist mit Ahmad, der jetzt auf der Schiene spielt und eben nicht mehr vorne. Und dadurch zumindest in der Offensive ein bisschen hilft. Da haben sie zwar defensiv dann das ein oder andere Problemchen, aber offensiv hat er einen weiteren inversen Spieler, den er ja so gerne drauf hat. Na, Amorim ist ja ein Fetischist in dem Punkt. Und dann gibt es noch so, also das sind jetzt so Sachen, die kann ich dir nicht belegen. Das ist einfach nur so der, vielleicht ist es aber von den Ergebnissen gelenkt. Ich habe das Gefühl, sie sind minimal sicherer in der Defensive geworden, sind ein bisschen aggressiver, sind ein bisschen mutiger geworden. Und sie sind etwas besser im zweiten Bälle aufsammeln, liegt vor allen Dingen dadurch, dass De Ligt oft ins Mittelfeld mit vorgeht. Und De Ligt in einer guten Phase kann ja immer noch ein richtig guter Mann sein. Das macht er okay. Das sind jetzt die positiven Dinge. Es bleiben aber die negativen und unter einer geschweiften Klammer steht da, sie sind immer noch brutal ausrechenbar.
Ja, okay. Und aber wenn du jetzt tippen müsstest, ich meine aktuell ist United siebter. Es ist aber so ein bisschen hinfällig über Tabellenpositionen zu sprechen, weil zwischen Tabellenplatz drei mit Chelsea und Tabellenplatz zwölf mit Brentford liegen vier Punkte. Also ja, aber jetzt eben davon gesehen, wo glaubst du ordnet sich United von der Stärke her ein?
Die große Frage ist, wie gehen sie jetzt weiterhin mit Rückschlägen um? Innerhalb eines Spiels hat es jetzt etwas besser ausgesehen, denn die sind nicht mehr völlig zusammengekracht, mit dem mal eine Aktion nicht funktioniert hat, wie in den Monaten zuvor. Sie haben aber jetzt zum zweiten Mal wieder zwei Gegentore in Folge kassiert. Und das halte ich immer noch für ein großes Problem, dass sie immer noch immer einen Punch kassieren können. Also wenn sie Platz sieben holen, dann wäre es Wahnsinn. Also dann würde ich das unterschreiben und sagen, das wäre tiptop. Ich kann es mir aber verfasst nicht vor. Also muss man von oben immer rechnen in der Premier League. Und da sind wahrscheinlich sechs Teams mindestens stärker und wahrscheinlich sogar sieben bis acht. Würde ich vermuten. Es dauert jetzt auch nur wieder eine gewisse Phase, bis dann der Rest wieder geschnallt hat, was sie jetzt machen. Und dann sind sie wieder exakt gleich ausrechenbar.
Das ist ja gut. Faire Punkt. Aber wenn es schon mal was Positives über Manchester United zu sagen gibt, dann soll es ja auch mal kurz stattfinden.
Darf ich kurz eine Frage zu United stellen? Weil ich sehe, Uli war beim Friseur, hat einen frischen Boxercut. Meine Frage ist, war der United-Fan denn endlich beim Friseur? Konnte er endlich die Tolle abschneiden?
Ich habe das gar nicht gecheckt, worum es da geht. Das haben mir ein paar Leute geschrieben, aber ich bin nicht...
Das ist seit einem Jahr ein Meme.
Es ging darum, es geht um einen Fan, der wollte sich erst die Haare schneiden, wenn United vier oder fünf Spiele in Folge gewinnen.
Ach so, dann darf er jetzt, oder? Ach so, dann gewinnt. Okay, dann gewinnt.
Und er hat jetzt so einen Afro seit einem Dreivierteljahr.
Ach so, okay, das tut mir leid, aber da bin ich...
Der Premier League Experte kriegt das nicht mit.
Das habe ich wohl... Also wir haben das jetzt... Nee, aber komisch, weil am Wochenende haben mich drei oder vier Leute geschrieben, dann kann der Fan immer noch nicht. Was für ein Fan.
Der ist ja so berühmt geworden, Oli, der macht für Paddy Power mittlerweile sogar Werbung.
Ach krass, okay.
Weil der hat natürlich seine Frisur so... Weil das so ein Ding ist. Also es ist wirklich geisteskrank, was der für eine Frisur hat.
Das ist aber auch ganz schön anspruchsvoll hier, ne? Also manche Fans sagen, ja, bis der Trainer entlassen wird oder bis hier und da viermal für ihr gewinnt. Also wie viele Vereine gibt es denn da?
Es gibt Leute, die wollen sich tätowieren lassen, wenn Trainer bis zum Jahresende da sind, ne? Also...
Aber damit ihr seht, welche Kreise das zieht. Celta Vigo, die ja selber nicht so gut sind, haben fünf Spiele in Folge gewonnen und haben diesen Kerl mit einer Glatze gefotoshoppt und einem Celta Vigo-Trikot so verringelt. Wenn du Celta-Fan wärst, würdest du so aussehen. So berühmt ist dieser United-Fan noch.
Das ist der Klassiker. Ab jetzt werde ich den andauernd sehen, ne? Andauernd.
Absolut.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nur überspielt. Ich weiß nicht.
Da müssen wir beim Match die Daumen drücken, dass sie noch zwei Spiele gewinnen. Oder was? Vier waren es? Vier?
Fünf sind es. Fünf.
Fünf, na gut, ja zwei Spiele.
Aber fünf in Folge ist ja wirklich gar nicht so leicht, ne? Ja, eben. Also da wird er in allen, wenn du nicht mehr in allen Wettbewerben bist.
Und sollen wir mal so sein. Haar wächst in alle Richtungen. Du hast das schon gut beschrieben. Die No-Win-No-Trim-Challenge, falls ihr es googeln wollt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich, ach wisst ihr was? Ich packe einfach ein Link in die Show notes. Dann könnt ihr euch ihn angucken. Frank Hillett heißt er.
Und dieses Gesicht auf seinen Kopf Photoshoppen, wenn du das auch möchtest, in diesem Thumbnail-Bild.
Ja, ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass Uli einsteigt in die Wette. Vielleicht gibt es einen Paddy-Power-Vertrag dafür, Uli.
Okay. Das würde hier zu Hause, zumindest bei einem Mitglied der Familie, für positiven Anklang sorgen, wenn ich dir die Haare wieder wachsen lassen würde. Aber ich kriege halt keinen Afro, sondern bei mir ist es dann eher, wie der Droger Willems immer so schön gesagt, zauerkrautartig.
Sehr schön. Sagen wir mal so, in diesem Haushalt hier gibt es ein Bewusstsein darüber, dass ich mal lange Haare hatte, aber ich werde immer noch regelmäßig dafür ausgelacht, weil sie mal bei den Großeltern ein Foto davon gesehen haben. Nun ja, das sind andere.
Pack das bitte auch in die Show notes.
Da wartet das Internet schon so lange drauf. Und es gab auch einmal…
Ich möchte die Haare als Thumbnail aussehen.
Also bitte, manche von euch dürften es schon gesehen haben. Mein Führerschein sieht immer noch so aus.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Jetzt werde ich immer rausgezogen. Ja, machen wir demnächst mal off-air. Jetzt blicken wir aber noch mal auf La Liga. Da gibt es noch ein kleines Thema. Alex, was ist denn da los?
Weniger La Liga mehr. Es ist ja International Break, also Länderspielpause. Deswegen ist es ein kleines passendes Länderspiel-Pausenthema. Also die Nationalmannschaft betreffend die Spanische. Es ist eine große Sache, aber für uns sportlich jetzt nicht so groß. Aber es geht um den Streit zwischen dem FC Barcelona und La Minia Mal. Der schwelt schon seit Monaten. Und jetzt wurde er wieder eingeladen. La Minia Mal hat ja Schamweinprobleme seit Monaten und kam am Montagmorgen zur Nationalmannschaft. Und danach kam der Ärzte-Report, der Befund des FC Barcelona. Der hat sich einer so nachschauen, invasiven Radiofrequenztherapie oder so unterzogen, also seiner Schamweinverletzung behandelt. Und der ärztliche Befund rät oder sagt vor, hier, der muss pausieren, der kann nicht spielen. Und musste dann wieder abreißen. Und dem Spanischen Verband hat das gar nicht geschmeckt. Denn der war ja schon eingereist, war schon da. Und die hatten das gar nicht am Schirm. Und dann gab es eine sehr, sehr erzürrende Pressebeteilung. Also sehr, sehr unhappierter Verband. Und auch de la Fuente, es ist ja in Spanien eh so ganggebe, dass sich alle gerne äußern bei Radiosendern, bei Fernsehsendern, viele Interviews geben. Also nicht nur die PK, sondern wirklich zu den Sendern gehen. Und de la Fuente hat sich dann zum Radiosender gesetzt und hat auch gesagt, ja, das schmeckt ihm gar nicht. Und sowas hat er noch nie erlebt und unprecedented. Und das kann nicht sein, dass es so abläuft. Und so schwelt dieser Kampf quasi weiter. Was ist der Hintergrund des Ganzen? Lamine Jamal hat seit zwei Monaten Scham beim Problem. Wir haben mehrere Spiele, ich glaube, Cole Palmer hat, glaube ich, das auch in England. Nico Williams fällt damit schon länger aus. Es ist immerhin eine schwierige, langwierige Sache, die du ja nicht einfach so behandeln kannst, sondern das zieht sich monatelang. Und Lamine Jamal hat das seit gut zwei Monaten, nämlich seit dem Länderspieleinsatz im September, Mitte September. Er hatte davor Probleme, konnte bei Barca nicht trainieren, wurde dann nominiert für die Nationalmannschaft. Konnte dort, weil er solche Schmerzen hatte, nicht am Training teilnehmen, wurde er aber in beiden Spielen der EM-Quali eingesetzt. Von 190 Minuten hat er, glaube ich, 160 gespielt. Unter Schmerzen, unter Einnahme von Medikamenten, ich glaube, eine Spritze hat er bekommen und hat das Ganze natürlich verschlimmert. Kam dann zurück zu Barca, konnte nicht eingesetzt werden, fiel aus. Und Barca hat das natürlich gar nicht geschmeckt. Hansi Flick hat sich negativ geäußert über den Umgang mit den Spielern bei der Nationalelf. Und so schweht quasi dieser Streit jetzt seit Monaten. Und jetzt hat Barca eben gesagt, ja, nee, unsere Ärzte gucken mal drauf. Nee, der darf nicht spielen. Und das schmeckt natürlich dem Verband jetzt nicht, weil das nicht sauber so vorab kommuniziert wurde, sondern erst, als er schon anreiste. Also das ist so ein kleines Thema, das aktuell die spanischen Gazetten und Medien so ein bisschen natürlich beschäftigt.
Ja, ich meine, eigentlich ist es natürlich gar kein kleines Thema, weil der Typ ist 18, hat unter Schmerzen spielen müssen. Es ist eh schon die Frage, wie viel Schmerzen sind eigentlich noch gesund, auch für Leistungssportler, wo Schmerzen nochmal was anderes sind als für Normalmenschen. Aber das ist schon relativ krass, wenn man sich das nochmal vor Augen führt. Und ob das jetzt dann mit dem Timing des Ärzte-Reports und so weiter, da kann man natürlich dann trefflich drüber diskutieren. Aber das ist ein sehr, sehr junger Mensch erstmal, eben ein bisschen mehr als 18 Jahre alt. Und da gibt es eigentlich auch eine Fürsorgepflicht. Ich sage mal so, der spanische Fußballverband ist ja zuletzt, egal ob bei Männern oder bei Frauen, jetzt nicht dadurch aufgefallen, gut organisiert zu sein, rücksichtsvoll gegenüber den eigenen SpielerInnen und so weiter und so fort.
Ich finde die Frage ist recht eindeutig, oder? Schmerzen sind nie gesund.
Generell ja. Natürlich ist das immer so eine Sache. Ein Verein hat natürlich seine Interessen, nämlich die Spieler möglichst zu schonen und nicht zu verheizen bei der Nationalmannschaft und die Nationalmannschaft hat ihre Interessen, die Top-Spieler einzusetzen, damit die Nationalmannschaft möglichst erfolgreich Fußball spielt und sich für eine WM qualifiziert. Da prallen natürlich Interessen und Konflikte aufeinander, aber wenn man eben weiß, dass Lamini Amal nicht trainieren konnte, Schmerzen hatte, trotzdem spielte und ich glaube, es war sogar im September das Türkei-Spiel. Da haben sie zur Halbzeit 5 zu 0 geführt in der Türkei und Lamini Amal wurde trotzdem nicht ausgewechselt, sondern erst in der 60. und 70. Obwohl er unter Schmerzen und Medikamenten spielte. Und das ist natürlich ein No-Go aus Trainer- und Vereinssicht. Und deswegen die Fürsorgepflicht von Nationalcoach de la Fuente und seinem spanischen Verband. Nicht immer optimal und deswegen verstehe ich völlig, wenn ein Spieler wirklich Probleme hat und er hat ja Schmerzen, er fiel ja auch bei einigen Spielen aus und wurde auch früh ausgewechselt. Also die denken sich das ja nicht aus. Der hat diese Scheinbar-Probleme, verstehe ich das völlig, dass du als Verein deinen Spieler schützen möchtest, weil ihn der Verband und Nationaltrainer eben nicht schützt.
Und es ist ein interessantes Thema, das auch Deutschland betrifft. Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit dem Frauen-U23-Team Deutschlands? Ich dachte es mir nämlich. Es hat nämlich nicht große Wellen geschlagen. Da wurde nämlich inzwischen bekannt und das ist verbrieft, dass wenn du absagst als Spielerin, du bist nominiert und du sagst ab, dann wirst du erstmal nicht mehr für die nächsten Länderspielmaßnahmen nominiert vom DFB. Und das ist nämlich ganz interessant, weil man da nämlich alle Komplexität dieser Fälle auch beleuchten kann. Weil im ersten Moment wirkt das total absurd, weil man sagt, was sollen Spielerinnen, die sich nicht wohlfühlen, müssen die jetzt– und da geht es ja zum Teil sogar noch um Minderjährige– müssen die jetzt quasi dann bestraft werden dafür. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es aber Fälle, bei denen tatsächlich Spielerinnen auch aus kleineren Gründen abgesagt haben. Also, was bekannt ist, ist zum Beispiel, dass jemand umgezogen ist in der Zeit und gesagt hat, ich kann da nicht, ich muss da umziehen und da kann ich dann auch den Verband verstehen, dass er sagt, es geht hier darum, ob du dich vielleicht irgendwann ins A-Team reinspielen kannst oder nicht. Und es gab noch andere Gründe, die sind allerdings nicht öffentlich kommuniziert, deswegen mache ich das jetzt hier an der Stelle auch nicht. Aber da gibt es nämlich genau die Diskussion und der DFB hat das quasi so gelöst, dass er gesagt hat, wenn jemand absagt, dann wird er erstmal nicht mehr nominiert. Welche Rolle da aber auch gesundheitliche Absagen spielen, dazu sagt der DFB nichts und das ist jetzt eine Diskussion, die müsste eigentlich hier in Deutschland mal geführt werden, aber ihr habt es nicht mitbekommen, viele haben es nicht mitbekommen.
Aber bei den spanischen Frauen war das rund um dieses rubiales Vergehen, das du vorhin glaube ich kurz angedeutet hast, Max, war das ja auch ein Riesenthema. Also dieser erzwungene Kuss auf, ich glaube, Jenny Hamosos war das, als die Weltmeisterin wurde, meine ich. Ja, und dann schlug das ja so krasse Wellen, dass ja die Spielerinnen des FC Barcelona ja die nächste Nominierung, als Rubiales noch im Amt war, boykottieren wollten und das nicht durften, weil ihnen vom Verband Sanktionen angedroht wurden. Also wenn dich die nationalen Mannschaften nominiert in Spanien, musst du kommen or else. Und die Sparserspanerinnen wollten eben nicht aus Protest gegen Rubiales und mussten aber, weil ihnen angedroht wurde, sonst werdet ihr gesperrt.
Aber im Gesicht des immer volleren Kalenders wird es ja immer mehr noch ein Thema werden die nächsten Jahre, dieser Konflikt zwischen nationalen Teams und Vereinen.
Ja bei Frankreich war es ja auch so. Bei Peer hatte er ja auch vor zwei Monaten, glaube ich, nicht so die Lust, mal wieder Quali zu spielen und hat dann mal ausgesetzt. Und jetzt kommt er mal wieder und dann muss es nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich dachte spontan gerade eher an den Fall Hakemi zum Beispiel, der jetzt bei Paris ausgefallen ist, für den aber ein Lebenstraum gerade in Frage steht, nämlich Afrika Cup in Marokko. Wo es jetzt heißt, Ode wird vielleicht Ende Dezember wieder fit. Und ich glaube aus Clubsicht wäre dir sehr lieb, wenn ein vielleicht wieder fit Spieler nicht direkt einen Großturnier spielt. Und gut, bei Olympia Mbappé konnte Real sagen, nein, ich glaube, da sind die Sachen nochmal anders.
Ist ja auch immer die Sache, wie reagiert der Nationaltrainer. Effektiv ja die letzte Instanz, die das entscheidet. Und bei Lamine Jamal ist er eben nicht happy drüber. Und vielleicht deschamp bei Mbappé hat gesagt, ja, kommen die zwei Spiele jetzt im September oder Juli oder was auch immer, dann verzichte du mal, sollst du dich ausruhen. Ist ja auch immer so ein Thema. Welche Umgangsformen herrschen da?
Ja klar, wie wichtig sind Freundschaftsspiele und so weiter oder Qualispiele.
Solche Sachen, ja.
Und ein kleiner medizinischer Beitrag noch. Schampeinentzündungen oder Pubalgia, wie sie auch in Italien spannen, extrem gefährlich, dass sie extremes Potenzial für Langfristigkeit haben. Also da gibt es in der Geschichte des Profifußballs viele große Namen in den letzten Jahrzehnten, die das dann jahrelang mit sich herumgeschleppt haben. Also das ist nicht was, was du vielleicht erst mal, ja, du hast eine akute Verletzung, pausierst vier Monate und dann bist du wieder da. So und das kannst du dir lange mitschleppen. Und gerade wie Max sagt, wenn es mit 18 schon losgeht. Das kann gefährlich werden für deine Karriere.
Tja, es ist einfach kein schönes Geschäft. Das Fußball-Business wird das besprechen. Das muss man echt sagen und auch an sowas magst du es halt dann. Aber gut, dann kommen wir mal nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, was hast du uns denn noch als zweites Thema mitgebracht?
Ich habe so einen kleinen Blick mitgebracht auf Twente Enthredder. Es ist so, dass von den größeren Vereinen in den Niederlanden, die in der Saison so ein bisschen schlecht abschneiden im Vergleich. Also wir haben ja neben Feyenoord, Ajax hier auch noch Utrecht z.B. oder Aset Alkmaar. Und da ist Twente aktuell auf dem achten Platz und damit hinter diesen allen. Auch Auftrag über Kroningen ist jetzt mittlerweile vor Twente und nach Nijmegen. Und das hat so ein bisschen auch zu tun, dass sie auch nach vier Spieltagen schon, eher fünf Spieltagen, die Träne ausgeschlissen haben. Josef Oosting, was ich sehr, sehr schade fand. Also der Start war stotternd, muss man sagen. Aus den ersten fünf Spielen haben sie vier Punkte jetzt geholt. Das war sehr unglücklich teilweise. Es war jetzt aber auch nicht so, dass Twente da zu Beginn irgendwie auseinandergebrochen ist. Das waren noch 2-0-2-1-Näherlagen, zugegeben wegen Zwolle und Excelsior und der Damm, also wegen Vereine, wo du da mindestens einen entschieden nicht holen musst mit dem Anspruch von Twente. Aber sie haben halt nur eins verloren und man musste sehr früh gehen. Das ist für mich eigentlich ein Beispiel für eine Traineranlassung, die zu voreilig war. Also ich habe Josef Rosting eigentlich mal sehr geschätzt, der kontinuierliche gute Arbeit leistet. Und, Klammer auf, könnte vielleicht ja auch ein Kandidat bei Ajax sein. Zumindest ist das so mein Kandidat, den ich mir gut vorstellen könnte. Klammer zu.
Wenn es den ergibt, dann wird es Ajax nicht machen. Sorry, dass ich es dir so deutlich sagen muss.
Ja, deswegen kommt er auch nicht. Schade, er ist Niederländer, er ist ablössefrei, weil er vereinzelt ist. Aber gut, das ist ein anderes Thema. Ja, dann ist es auch schon so, dass unter dem neuen Trainer jetzt, unter John von den Brom, Twente eigentlich einen Traumstart seitdem hingelegt, nämlich drei Siege in Folge geholt. Und dann auch die Offensive, die so ein bisschen gelahmt hat, wieder belebt, auch gleich ein 5-2-1 gegen Sparta oder Damm erzielt. Und von den Brom hat so ein bisschen gegen den Trend gearbeitet in der Liga. Also viele Teams lassen dieses 4-2-3-1 jetzt spielen. Und von den Brom ist es zurück zu einem 4-3-3, hat die Fokus mehr auf Risiko gelegt, mehr auf Offensive gelegt. Und das hat sich zuerst ausgezahlt. Aber jetzt scheint auch wieder so ein bisschen der Motor wieder weiter zu stottern. Es gab auch viele unentschiedene Fanierenlagen wieder. Und vor allem durch diese Risiko-behafete Spielanlage auch wieder mehr Gegentore. Gestern 3 Tore gegen Neymich und beim 3-3. Dann das schon erwähnte 2-3 gegen Ajax mit 3 Gegentoren. Und gegen Groningen dann auch nur 1-1. Aber auch wieder mit Gegentor. Also es hat sich quasi verschoben. Bei Oosting war es zuletzt in den ersten Spielen keine Tore erzielt. Dafür aber ein verhältnismäßiges Wien nicht nur kassiert. Unter dem Neutrigen hat es jetzt ein bisschen umgedreht. Das heißt, die Balance fehlt da einfach noch so ein bisschen. Und man muss aber auch dazu sagen, dass Oosting vor der Saison keinen Leichtstand hatte, weil einfach auch viele Spieler weggebrochen sind. Also Sam Stein, Stefano, Satellegis, Flapwäck. Das sind bei Twente alles Namen, die eine große Rolle gespielt haben, das ist die Saison. Und die konnten nicht wirklich aufgefangen werden. Sie haben jetzt einen Novica geholt für 6 Millionen, quasi der Königstransfer in dieser Saison bei Twente, Sontre, Earth Yater. Ich hoffe, den Namen wird so ausgesprochen. Es gibt unter den Ligatour-Krämelatoren verschiedenste Aussprache-Varianten. Ja, aber der hat auch noch, links außen, hat in zehn Spielen noch null Tore erzielt. Also das ist so ein bisschen, hat es noch nicht so eingeschlagen, wie man es erhofft hatte. Und gerade mit den Abgängen hat das Ostdingen auch nicht so einfach gehabt. Deswegen kam auch dafür nicht zu früh. Und jetzt muss man schauen, wie es sich entwickelt. Immerhin, die einzelnen Ergebnisse waren jetzt schon wieder auf dem Weg der Besserung. Auch wenn es jetzt nach diesen drei siegenden Folgen wieder ein bisschen gearbeitet hat, zeigen sie sich schon stabil. Wenn der Platz der Bänders 8, den Twente Real hat, zu einem Platz 3 wird, dann zeigt das aber auch, finde ich, das ist ein Indiz dafür, dass die Spiele halt immer zu ungunsten Twentes ausgegangen sind. Ja, dass sie eigentlich im Prinzip schon ihre Chancen hatten, auch unter Ostim-Offensiv, muss man auch sagen, dass sie insofern ihre Chancen schon hatten und eigentlich unterperformen und zwar auch relativ deutlich, zumindest auf diesen X-Ranks, das ist eine nette Spielerei. Auf diesen X-Ranks ist übrigens Ajax auf Platz 9, also auch Ajax, obwohl Ajax stolpert in der Saison, performen sie demnach trotzdem noch über, das ist auch eine nette Rappnotiz.
Quasi die Generation X.
Ja, Generation X.
Also ich lese gerade das aktuelle Buch von Christoph Biermann, die La Tabelle lügt immer und kann euch sagen, es ist eh alles völlig irrelevant, was wir hier tun. Der Zufall hat so einen großen Einfluss im Fußball. Da wir dürften eigentlich gar nicht über Fußball sprechen. So ist das. Also das ist die Situation bei Twente. Ich habe kurz überlegt, ob ich dir helfen kann bei der Aussprache von Oya Zeta. Aber das Name sieht ja schon normal geschrieben so aus, wie die Logos von Bands, die ich gerne höre. Deswegen da bin ich dann tatsächlich auch mal aufgeschmissen. Danke dir, Daniel. Wir schauen noch ein letztes Mal in die Serie A, Christian. Jetzt musst du entscheiden, über was du noch sprechen möchtest.
Ja, dann müssen wir wohl Atalanta auflösen, weil es ja beim letzten Ligatour angesprochen wurde.
Da lobt man einmal Juric.
Genau. Also Ivan Juric ist nicht mehr Trainer von Atalanta seit wenigen Tagen. 0-3 zu Hause gegen Sassuolo wurde ihm zum Verhängnis. Und jetzt haben wir den Punkt. Atalanta hat zwar kaum verloren in der Saison, siebenmal unentschieden gespielt in der Liga, aber hat halt auch kaum gewonnen. Sprich, von elf Ligaspielen haben sie jetzt nur zwei gewonnen, sind Tabellen 13, haben schon neun Punkte Rückstand auf dem Champions League-Platz. Und dementsprechend ist es für Juric jetzt blöd gelaufen. Die letzten zwei Niederlagen in der Liga, jeweils ohne eigenes Tor, haben jetzt dazu geführt, dass er, dass er sich von ihm getrennt wurde. Rafaela Palladino, der Nachfolger, Ex-Fiorentina-Trainer, auch ein Gasparini-Schüler. Sehr spannend, da haben einige schon im Sommer gehofft, dass er das vielleicht übernehmen könnte. Jetzt darf er es mit ein paar Wochen, Monaten Verzug machen. Ja, und zu Juric irgendwie, er hatte Landtag vor kurzem, er hat die Marseille gewonnen in der Champions League, da musste er auch erstmal gewinnen, also so viele gewinnen da nicht. Steht in der Champions League auch gar nicht so schlecht da, gleich viele Punkte wie Barca, gleich viele, sieben Punkte, gleich viele wie Barca, gleich viele wie Chelsea. Und dementsprechend ist ihm jetzt wirklich so, die letzten Spiele in der Liga sind ihm zum Verhängnis geworden. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen atmosphärisch, um es vielleicht kurz zu erklären. Es gab schon einen öffentlichen Disput mit Karnesecki, mit einem Nationaltorhüter, der hat vor wenigen Spielen mal nach dem Spiel gemeint, hey, wer müde ist bei uns, der soll sagen, also wir brauchen mehr Intensität. Da meinte Juric danach, er soll doch bitte weiter Bälle halten und nicht öffentlich reden. Also da hat man so gemerkt, dass intern und Karnesecki hat das wirklich nicht aggressiv formuliert, sondern ich glaube, er wollte einfach ein bisschen Verantwortung übernehmen. Mit Luckmann gab es jetzt in der Champions League eine Auseinandersetzung, wie von den TV-Kameras eingefangen wurde. Also Juric ist wohl nicht mit Alden ganz warm gewesen und deswegen haben sie wohl auch deshalb reagiert und vielleicht von seiner Art, Fußball zu spielen. Ich meine, die Nachfolge von Gasparini bei Atalanta nach neun Jahren zu übernehmen, glaube ich, wäre für jeden sehr schwer gewesen. Die Idee von Atalanta war eben, da jemand zu installieren, der einfach diese Art und Weise, nicht nur fußballerisch, sondern auch vielleicht von der Trainingsintensität einfach fortführt. Aber Juric ist es ganz ein bisschen konservativ angegangen. Und Atalanta, die Spieler in der Mannschaft, die sind es jetzt unter Waren, das unter Gasparini gewöhnt, auch ein bisschen mehr Risiko zu gehen. Und das hat vielleicht nicht so ganz zueinander gepasst. Viele Spiele, finde ich, kann man Juric nicht angreiten. Da haben die Stürmer wahnsinnig viele Chancen liegen lassen. Also Atalanta hätte auch deutlich mehr Spiele gewinnen können als unentschieden. Aber wahrscheinlich war es jetzt atmosphärisch so ein bisschen, dass die Percassis, also die Eigentümer, die Reißleine gezogen haben. Und wie gesagt, Palladino sehr spannend. Mit der Fiorentina letztes Jahr 66 Punkte gemacht. Gasperini, Schüler, ja, vielleicht ist es jetzt der, der dem Ganzen noch ein bisschen mehr Leben einhaucht bei Atalanta. Denn das Spielerpotenzial ist da, hat man auch in der Champions League gesehen. Also ich freue mich auf Palladino.
Und man kann sich, glaube ich, auch auf sein erstes Spiel jetzt dann freuen. Auswärts in Neapel, also das wäre ja so ein Klassiker, wenn jetzt Atalanta da mal wieder das alte Gesicht zeigt. Dann übrigens bei Eintracht Frankfurt, bevor man dann wiederum zu Hause gegen Florenz spricht. Über die können wir jetzt nicht mehr sprechen, aber nur kurz, dass ihr es gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Immer noch sieglos am Tabellenende der Serie A werden wir sicherlich in einer der nächsten Folgen dann mal ausführlicher draus schauen. Ihr fünf, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat große Freude gemacht, wie immer. Große Runde, viele Themen. Wir haben alles wieder mit dabei gehabt. Herzlichen Dank. Ich sage es jetzt einfach mal so in die Runde an Daniel Zander, Christian Bernhardt, Uli Hebel, David Frogier de Port-le-Voie und Alex Treuker. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Danke an dich.
Danke an alle.
Sehr gut. Die alten Reflexe, sie sitzen noch beim David. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, alles, was es hier im Rasenfunk gibt, das gibt es nur dank euch. Hier gibt es keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren und vor allem auch keine Paywall. Und wie können wir uns das alles dann leisten? Auch unsere Hörer, Gästehonorare, Entschuldigung, Hörerhonorare gibt es noch nicht. So weit sind wir noch nicht. Da müsst ihr zu Anfang.
Dividende.
Ja, genau. Die Rasenfunk-Dividende, um Gottes Willen. Also, wie ist es möglich, nur dank eurer freiwilligen Unterstützung ganz dividendlos. Und da bedanke ich mich in dieser Folge bei Ulli the Hero, bei Wilmes, bei Klaus Tim, bei Philipp Maria und bei U unterstrich Hoeneß. Es ist aber nicht der und U unterstrich Hoeneß, denn ich kann hier noch sehen, wie sein Klarname ist. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt. Außerdem auch in der Videobeschreibung dieses Videos und natürlich auch in der Podcastbeschreibung dieses Podcasts. Wir sehen einfach alles gleichzeitig. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Hört auch sehr gerne in andere Folgen des Rasenfunk rein und abonniert mal das Tribütengespräch, denn da wird morgen, wenn alles gut geht, eine Folge erscheinen, die auch mit internationalem Fußball zu tun hat. In diesem Sinne, macht's gut und bis bald. Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!